do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do we live we
bid love baby I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark
Renard oddly muffled right yeah got to
get right up there oh yeah ooh that
sounds now we could hear it in the room
we're wearing our masks we're wearing
our gloves it's a Friday night at the
scum and villainy Cantina look at all
these people that it's crazy with
invisible men we're we're practicing our
distancing we're being as safe as we can
ladies and gentlemen put this away for
later we're here to chitchat on a Friday
night just got paid yeah oh my god
it is so time to talk about comic books
and the world of comic books on this
show we tend to talk about a lot of
things comic book related but very
rarely did we talk about comic books my
good friend Mark Barnard was like we
should talk about how the retailers are
doing in all this and I was like
retailers I was like wait oh no I know
something about that so that's what
we're gonna do up top we're gonna shift
the order we're gonna do our news later
on and stuff because we got to get our
special guests up and running so they
can go out on with their night and stuff
like that so here we are at the scum and
villainy Cantina on Hollywood Boulevard
in Hollywood California last week me and
Mark did this show as a benefit for the
cantina this week mark tell them what
it's a benefit for it's a benefit for us
give the man a [ __ ] clothes up yeah
it's over there yeah yeah I got a I got
a DM on the Twitter's from a comic book
writer named Donny Cates okay it was
like dude I'm a really big fan of the
show I love it but I think that that
right now we could all do a little bit
to help raise awareness for the plight
of the comic book retail
okay because they are being hit as hard
if not harder than most small businesses
simply because they were already a
little bit on the you know on the comic
comic book community the comic book
retail community yes has been not the
healthiest retail community but holding
in there and stuff and when you tend to
do it a lot of stores do it more for the
love than the like I'm swimming and
money you know what I'm saying so it's a
passion like project you know and so
because people can't go into the stores
anymore they're being forced to find
different ways to get comic books to
their customers and then diamonds shut
down for a couple of months and so there
wasn't even any new merchandise for the
micelle but and so you know the idea of
doing a sort of fundraiser for the comic
book retailer community felt really good
to both of us and so you know the tip
jar is open and the proceeds from the
tip jar gonna go to the [ __ ] foundation
bi NC foundation.org and they are the
sort of this this community this this
initiative that's helping to raise money
for independent booksellers of which
comic book retailers are a big part of
there are other charities other people
are doing the comic book creators for
the retail comics but tonight it's [ __ ]
it's been your gig all of them are fun
like the creators for comics all those
auctions you've seen on Twitter the last
couple of days are all funneling that
money right to [ __ ] which is helping to
get that money to retailers who need it
back to those retailers and just so
nobody out there was just like why are
we [ __ ] giving money he's gonna give
it to his comic store I am not giving
anything we're giving it all the bank
and I don't think in our world were
reaching out to [ __ ] or anything like
that I spoke to Michael zap sick the
other day of course one of the comic
book men from AMC's comic book men seven
seasons it's poor one out
and a movie Seventeen's in a movie only
Wow they wound up in Jay and Silent Bob
reboots the scene in a movie so I talked
his absurd because a man like what was a
Danny Kaye Donny K Shani Cates he's
Marvel writer right yeah so I saw a
story where he was in his comic book
store in Austin he like bought
everybody's reserved books
yeah they're pull boxes their PO Box I
said
it's [ __ ] sweet man I said I'm gonna
do it Donny Cates so I told Mike I said
empty the PO Box send everything to
every reservist man like just in this
time like enjoy your books and [ __ ] like
that
so I pulled from that cat ya know it's
like alright [ __ ] I'm gonna do it too
it's a really jobs move and there's a
lot of the creators I mean I think the
way it's working is people are just like
hey do you want to have a half an hour
conversation with Tom King about Batman
or whatever and have him read a script
sure bid for it and all that money all
the proceeds are the money and that's
happening soup-to-nuts across the board
everybody's digging stuff out of their
closets like one-of-a-kind things things
nobody's ever seen before signed
original art mm-hmm and we'll talk to
Jim about it cuz Jim Lee has been doing
this 60 days 60 sketches challenge where
like every day he's drawing a cover
sketch cover and people bid on it online
and the person who bids the highest gets
to pick them next to cover and Jim on
the line where are you holy crap I mean
this is that's I've watched him and he
came to my house and did fat man I'm
Batman back in the day he sat there
drawn the whole time and he drew up this
beautiful Harley piece that hangs in my
house and the hallway and stuff so I you
know I in terms of 60 in 60 days he's up
to the challenge I've seen him draw he's
fast it's up to the challenge and like
been doing sketches like the bids for
them you know because he very generously
he texted me and a group of friends who
say hey I'm doing this dead man comic
send me a picture of you lit like this
and I'll put you on the cover I was like
oh that's [ __ ] dope and so I did the
picture as he asked and lo and behold a
couple hours later he puts the sketch up
online and it's there's my face like in
the lower right hand corner oh [ __ ] and
I got a decent job and luckily still
getting paid like maybe I'll bid on this
and maybe I'll maybe I'll buy my own
sketch cover and then like an hour into
the into the eBay auction it was like
$9,000 like it's just a [ __ ] sketch I
know what I look like the picture I
shaved it off of Instagram how beautiful
to be able to draw money for people yeah
at a time when they really need it and
also this isn't just like you know
the world's greatest artists and a comic
book legend and [ __ ] this guy that runs
a company like you know those cats are
not boots on the ground looking out for
the retailer so this is an incredibly
sweet thing and we have them oh my god
like it cats I sounded I'm looking out
for the retailer so this is an
incredibly sweet thing and we happen oh
my god yeah let's kill them all right
speakers in the place not Jim yeah Jim
give us one sec we were just sealing our
damn selves and stuff I don't have
volume can you not hear us I can hear
you now I think how are you man we'll
get up in the mics little more ladies
and gentlemen is the legend Jim Lee give
it up for Jim Lee everybody thanks for
having me guys thanks for being here sir
you're an old fat man on Batman veteran
so to speak let me ask you this
it's a Friday night what are you drawing
right now cuz you got to do apparently a
drawing a day tell us about the 60 and
60 challenge yeah so yeah I mean I set
myself up for this I don't think I've
ever drawn stuff for 60 days in a row I
I didn't realize this until like day 15
you know but I'm working on this half of
this other sketch I did this last night
or today it's the Huntress from like
Batman hush I don't know if you can see
it kind of the lighting is not ideal
here gorgeous but it's a Gordon's kind
of drew her in that Batman series and
then it's a diptych right it's a fancy
art term for another piece that kind of
ties into it so there's a Batman head
that's in the background here in the
city and it's gonna be Deathstroke on
the left side there so yeah the way it's
set up is the high bidders on each
sketch get to pick the next one in the
queue that I draw and so I got the eye
so I got both of these kind of rounded
at the same time within hours of each
other I said what can I do to do
something different I've done 15 of
these already I got to keep challenging
myself in some way because you start
running out of energy and I I kind of
myself into this one I did this one of
the salmon and the endless I don't know
if you guys saw it but I just put
countless hours into and I was like what
am i doing this was not this was not the
original plan the original plan was just
to do like quick little head shots it
would take like 30 minutes and I cranked
out one a day kind of like while I'm on
the phone or you know eating pop-tarts
or over breakfast and and I just got
into the whole spirit of like what yeah
let's raise as much money as we can and
and you know you guys know I mean
comments mean everything to me and the
retailers and and keeping that these
stores you know up and running and so I
just got inspired I think by also the
reaction of the people and you know
online they're going like this is the
best one yet so every time you see that
it just wants you to like it makes you
want to do a better one the next time
and then a better one the next time and
so it was a yeah it's become a big thing
now so I got to figure out ways to keep
my creatively creativity flowing and you
know inspiration going and it's been an
interesting journey only 25 percent of
the way through so I got a lot more
ahead of me are you icing your hand are
you like how are you taking care of the
instrument cuz that's a lot of work for
guys you have a corner man where you're
like cut me man i can't hear mark hold
on a second Jim I'm gonna go to the
YouTube no I might be delayed
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you sound good though I like listening
are you okay I was trying to time it so
I could hear you and then respond there
be a delay but I can't I can't hear you
the audio cut out so can you hear come
on we're trying what happened we're
trying to work on it right now
I didn't do anything no we don't blame I
promise did you do that can you hear
this we should start writing and hold up
signs not Penny's boat I can hear chimes
I can hear people donating money hey
you're right man I saw your that I could
hear Kevin all right you hear that out
we're to hear me yeah nice hit of mark
excellent
my question was like are you icing your
hand are you like how are you taking
care of yourself this seems like a like
a marathon not a sprint
yeah it hasn't gotten to that point but
I have done that before you know when I
first started drawing comics I wasn't
used to drawing you know eight ten hours
a day every day and I used to have to
run my my right hand you know under hot
I'll turn anything hot and cold water
now what kind of hunched over and
pinched a nerve and my dad is a doctor
got me this brace that kind of hold your
shoulders back to kind of alleviate that
but actually now I just feel a little
numbness in my fingertips because I'm
holding the pen like special with all
that line work you're just doing line
after line and pressing down really hard
and it just kind of numbs your
fingertips a bit but other than that I
mean look I'm sitting at a chair you
know in a well heated room with you know
access to the Internet it it's a pretty
cushy way to raise money it's not like
I'm running you know 20 miles or
something like that so I'm happy to to
sacrifice the body let me ask you this
what is the character you're least
looking forward to drawing did not catch
that at all what what's the character
you know what is the character you look
least forward to drawing like oh there's
gonna be a pain in the ass
I hesitate to say because I know that
some winters gonna throw head at me but
usually like crypto or any sort of
animal creature right
yeah just animals in general like have a
different Anatomy right it's not a human
that has that stands on its you know
arms and legs they have different joints
which and I can kind of draw one that
looks like a photograph that's a static
shot but to draw an animal in motion
right to kirby fight or give it that be
some kind of fluidity requires really
deep understanding of that musculature
and how it works and you know I have to
kind of fake it most of the time like I
had to draw a rat one time and I think I
use Chucky Cheese as my inspiration
because I couldn't think I couldn't
figure out how to draw rad so I had to
look to a cartoon to figure out I don't
know it's tricky man you you know like
drawing superheroes and figures is one
thing but doing caricatures and animals
it's a whole different like kind of
subfield of artistry
it's an incredibly wonderful gesture and
we were just saying like before we even
got you in the line like you know not
only are you legendary comic book
artists one of the world greats and
whatnot world's greats but you you're
also your guy that runs like a company
as well you're a businessman and like
you never hear of like some CEO going
like all draw some [ __ ] I'm gonna make
60 cars in 60 days ya know it's it's
kind of like my look it's it's uh it's
my passion and it actually makes the two
balance each other out
you know I mean there I've been just a
freelancer working from home I've done
the you know the day job the the
executive worked for now ten years at DC
I ran my own company for many years
before that so I find that they both
kind of provide a counterbalance to each
other you know so when you get when
you're working like four o'clock the
morning drawing against a deadline you
know how can I do this as a living like
this is so I you know stressful and hard
and so you embrace though the normalcy
of a regular
you know nine to six sort of schedule
but then when you're in these endless
meetings you know about you know budgets
and whatever and those are very usually
very exciting I don't want to put those
down the finance department so they're
super exciting but sometimes like the
numbers can kind of just become a blur
and you kind of go like I'm gonna treat
myself I'm going to draw tonight and
it's sort of a happy escape from kind of
dealing with a day job right so and I'm
very fortunate and that you know DC
Warner Bros allows me to do both and
it's a great balance that I find gives
me a lot of happiness enjoy the we saw
that DC is gonna start shipping books
and next week or something like that no
so it would be the last week in April so
the week of 4:28 yeah beautiful so that
in terms that means stories new stories
will be written and stuff in terms of
the creative is everybody just writing
about kovat in their stories at this
point a Superman going to be tackling
the enemy actually there are already
some stories that were coincidentally in
our storylines already but I think most
creators know not to jump on something
this big because you know everyone's
going to tackle a and how do you do it
justice without you know trivializing it
or insulting people you know particular
point of view particularly since we're
still in the middle of it you know I
think those kinds of stories work best
when you use that as inspiration for
something bigger and you make a parable
or some sort of allegory to something
that we you know are dealing with in in
real life but ours like the comics
shipping those are actually the books
that didn't ship April first right those
boats didn't ship so we're actually
taking a subsection of those we're not
releasing the whole line it's like the
the marketplace is on a diet they
haven't eaten for like a month you can't
just give them real food and a ton of it
at once you've got to slowly kind of
release it back into the pipeline and
the whole idea is to get some books in
to basically stress test this new these
new distributors that we've partnered
with and we're holding back the big
titles like Batman
- which had over 230,000 copies we want
to wait hold that for when the most
number of eyeballs you know can see it
and read it and things like death metal
those are likely going to continue to be
pushed back until we have more stores up
in line but until then we want to really
the stores that are open and have
figured out ways to be in business we
want to we want to help them out we want
to give them product to sell we want to
give them the lifeblood that kind of
keeps their their their businesses and
flow one last question that I'll turn
over Marc so during all this time work
even though Diamond was distributing
what were you guys doing digital or did
you stop digitally yeah we've been doing
digital since 2010 yeah for ten years
but I mean even gern all this like ever
you could be reading weekly comics
digitally or did you that stop with the
weekly books no no we always have weekly
comics that were day and date they came
out the same time as the physical books
so we've helped we believe you know
they've generally come out the same day
and so we're gonna continue that so we
won't release Batman 92 in digital form
before it comes out on print and then we
had something called digital first that
we innovated about ten years ago nine
years ago where we were producing like
shorter snippets of content about eight
pages worth for 99 cents it's a product
that you can't really sell physically in
a store but then we would it was just
kind of a windowing strategy we have
these short bursts of content that
people on mobile devices could read
consume and very quick you know amounts
of time and then we would take those and
repackage them either as comic books or
trim paperbacks and we had great success
when we did a bunch of comics type of
the injustice video game we did a budget
digital first comics that were short
eight page mini chapters and then when
we finally collected that into a
hardcover book it sold you know tens of
thousands copies in the direct market in
the moment you know the mom-and-pop
brick-and-mortar stores so there is a
precedent for being able to do digital
do it right do it for the native digital
reader and figure out a way to sell it
also in print later and I think you know
we're exploring all these things going
forward very nice I I noticed Jim on
your on your Instagram that other
creators other artists have been
either being roped in by you were
jumping on how did those guys get
involved was it Lyra them just saying
hey I'd like to be part of this too or
was there outreach on your part and who
are some of those guys no IIIi I made it
a point my started said I wouldn't
contact anyone just because I I think
you know being a publisher I would hate
to feel like I forced someone to kind of
participate so I didn't reach out to
anyone I figured I would do it and and
then maybe other people would just
follow by example and do their own thing
and do something similar but I had
artists reach out to me directly you
know they would you know DM me and said
hey this is cool how can I be a part of
this with guys like art Adams Jeff Scott
Campbell Brian hitch Toni Daniel Joe
Bennett I mean they've all and I've got
now a long list of people I've got Frank
Miller is lined up Bilson cabbage Walt
Simonson you know yeah so there's a lot
of guys ready to do more and I'm kind of
my spotlight one a day and it's kind of
cool because I can kind of talk a little
bit about who they are and what they
mean to me and the influences a lot of
these guys are you know huge influences
on my own work and I looked up to him
like they were gods to me when I was a
kid growing up and reading comic books
so it's great to be able to kind of you
know put them on a pedestal and kind of
tout their work and then see what they
come up with because you know our dams
and this Wolverine drawing was just you
know mind-blowing I was like I wonder if
I could like bid on this like what is
that unethical you know you know I'm
excited to see what they all come up
with what's gonna happen to the will
fans be able to see this order collected
is DC gonna collect a book of these and
be able to then sell those for charity
Lego or what's the plans for this going
forward yeah I think we haven't
finalized it but we've had a lot of
internal discussions about what we can
do with it and that you know I think it
has to be meaningful and to be
appropriate and you know and you know be
great to time something like that when
more stores are open so I think there
was a reason when I started like in the
back of head you know the publisher had
on I was like you know what Jim the
artist you should just draw DC
characters because there's more stuff we
can do if you just
alright Jim the publisher and so that's
what I've done the other artists that
are jumping in they can draw whatever
they want you know but but I knew I was
foregoing some sales like I did like an
x-men piece or something I knew I could
probably auction that off for a fair
amount but but I figure out what stayed
true to DC and to keep myself to keep
the possibility of doing some sort of
project like you guys were mentioning
alive and so we'll see what happens
there's some multi-millionaire x-men
fans somewhere who was like I was really
hoping for a Psylocke it's amazing look
I actually didn't even know if there
would be enough people to bid on this
stuff you know cuz there's not like you
know exhume art comic book art
collectors but it's been very gratifying
to see that the winners there's one guy
the money manager out of Texas that
bought like five or six of them but the
rest of gone to different people and and
what you're finding is they're finding
their favorite characters right
characters like dead man or big Barda
and stuff I've never drawn before really
and so it's been a lot of fun for me car
that you know artistically creatively
doing new stuff and that and I think
these collectors are digging seeing me
draw something different outside of my
normal comfort zone if we're kin if
we've got fans watching who have crazy
money and stuff based on our ticker
right now does not seem to be the case
but imagine imagine we have somebody
watching who's like oh my god I totally
want this where can they even see where
can they bid where can they see this
election yeah so if they go to my
Instagram page instagram.com slash Gimli
in my bio there's a link to all the
current auctions on eBay or you can go
to ebay and search for username chunky
monkey zero zero zero zero which is me
yeah are you sure that you cuz I think I
got dick pics from chunky monkey zero
zero zero three one
it was a long time ago yeah when I say
when I say dick pics of course I mean DC
dick right there
Dick Grayson sketch yes yeah it's total
yeah private dick I was telling these
cats right before you jumped on that
like when you were at the house - in fat
man on Batman you drew that gorgeous
Harley peas which eggs in my hallway
framed is fantastic of Harley like
working Batman and Joker puppets men
like over the course of we would talk
two maybe three hours or something like
that and bam he did this thing was so
beautiful so I've seen you work fast to
hear that you're taking your time and
like trying to make it like perfect like
take it from an old pro man good enough
is good enough I'm telling you like I do
regret I not regret but there's a part
of me that's going like what were you
thinking you know the the non the Gimli
that's not the publisher of the artist
like but the normal the husband right
the the father's like go on what were
you thinking he knew that that these
would get harder and harder to do and
sure enough that they've gotten
progressively longer and more
challenging to complete and I think it's
partly because I want to keep one-upping
myself as much as possible it's
beautiful stuff to look at Marx right
man collecting all that and a book like
then yes you get to go out there and
raise more money and stuff but what a
sweet guy you are you're always such an
incredibly kind human being in the midst
of working in like like you work for
corporation you work for Warner Brothers
and you still got a big heart man thank
you very much and thank you again for
that interview we did years ago I still
have so many people come up to me at
conventions and and and kind of talk
about the stuff that we talked about and
you know so it was one definitely the
most memorable interview that I've done
it's still as day I love Bern Miller
Bern how he runs you want to see you
have anything I just have one question
man growing up what was your a comic
book store like where did you where did
you first go in and buy comics for the
first time yeah so when I was a little
kid like when I was like 10 or 11 I had
a banana bike and I would drive like
I would ride my bike for like hours like
this was before cell phones right and so
I would just leave the house and I'd
come back when it got dark but I would
remember riding up along you know little
you know roads and going to a 7-eleven
that's kind of where I bought most of my
comics and then later a book store
carried a small selection and then
finally when I could start driving there
was a story I grew up in st. Louis
there's a store about 30 minutes away
from being Kirkwood but it was a tiny
little story it was next to a railroad
track and it was probably it was like
probably six feet across and ten feet
deep like it was like a claw a long
closet and it just had like long boxes
or short boxes on each side and but
that's where I bought my comics I don't
remember the name of them you know if
they had a name they had no signage but
the owner was friends with Rick Burkett
who's a artist that worked at DC of
works you know did Batman adventures and
he was like the first pro of working Pro
that I met so I learned a lot from the
the people that I at the store they kind
of mentored me and gave me advice on how
to break in and how to improve my work
and we started inking or working out on
small independent projects together and
that was kind of like my triple-a kind
of experience before I broke in that
normal I mean it was more than just a
place to buy comics that's what I'm
trying to say yeah you like the rest of
us you've seen the images Matt Reeves
and the Batman crew have put online and
stuff you've probably seen way more than
we've seen how exciting is it to see
this incarnation to see what they're
doing this time around with the Batman
as a guy who had probably drawn Batman
more than maybe anybody in this world at
this point thank you I've drawn a lot
and I'll tell you that I've drawn
different incarnations now the character
and I think you always start from the
place that you like the version that you
visualize in your head because that's
the version that you loved as a kid but
then once you've worked on it for a
while you realize you know people
everyone likes different versions of
Batman long years short ears Kelly Jones
Batman Neil out is Batman and so you
open yourself up more to the
possibilities of
artistic expression and so it's exciting
to me when you have a filmmaker like
Matt come in and do his interpretation
of Batman and you can see some of the
influences from even you know the Adam
West Batman show that the fact that he's
going very stripped-down with the
Batmobile
it's very muscular looking and and the
sets are beautifully dark and gothic you
can see that he's going for something
very different but true the spirit of
the character and and real detective
story I mean he's I'm not really
breaking any news he said this so I
think it's really cool that we're gonna
explore that aspect of the character
because I think there's more to the
character than people realize and there
are all these different facets and it's
great to show so the broad range that
Batman can can can be or the type you'd
be the detective the crime fighter the
superhero you know the brooding loner
the the leader of the bat family there's
all these different versions of the
character and it's exciting to see what
what he's going to do with her you know
in a world where they just announced
Justice League dark JJ Abrams bad robot
doing Justice League dark who first put
Justice League dark together at DC who's
was that whose problem that was
something that came out of the new 52
you know I think we had a bunch we
brought back some of the DC characters
that went over to vertigo and helped
seat that line we felt very goo is on
its feet and so we brought back
characters like Constantine Swamp Thing
brought them back into DC where they
first started and I think it was the
idea of hey you can create a team of
characters that deal with the occult the
mystical side of the the DC universe and
how that would play sort of
counterbalance the Justice League that
take on more traditional you know eight
alien invasions and traditional super
villains and so I think it was it came
out of that and it was just an
interesting way of kind of expanding the
Justice League franchise and so it's
exciting to see someone of JJ's caliber
kind of come in and express interest in
this world because we know he's going to
do it right and so it's very exciting to
see that kind of get get that brought
into prominence because there was some
interest early on
years ago and then it kind of waned kind
of the project kind of was put off to
the side so it's great to see it
resurrected oh my god that's right there
was Guillermo working on a version how
awesome we live in a world now where
we're gonna see Justice League dark
that's so nuts and the sky's the limit
at this point with like what is it on
Warner would be HBO Macs HBO Mac so like
HBO Mac seems like those cats are just
like you want to make an expensive DC
show come here yeah I look forward to
how much more they're gonna be able to
pull from you guys library and stuff I'm
you know I'm longtime DC guy so this
exciting time indeed you're doing the
Lord's work as per usual sure sir thank
you for taking time on a Friday night
for us thank you for having me thank you
so much man everyone give it up for Jim
Lee goddamn legend thank you Jim all
right thank you guys take care
later come on man that's awesome what a
sweet man great guy anything think about
all that damn drawing but you what a
great idea put it onto a book I mean
just part dude you should be running
[ __ ] with him you already thought of it
so weird I see that coming
I'm a writer this is why I watch movies
and I'm like how did that happen and I'm
like I should know better myself
like I [ __ ] remember watching
Mulholland Drive were David Lynch's
movie movie ended I was like what the
[ __ ] happened what was that about my
wife was like oh and she explained it
and I was like I realize I'm not that
bright all right so that was [ __ ]
thrilling and technologically I mean we
got there did she have it I feel [ __ ]
good about we didn't start there we got
there well done everybody well done what
was your first comic book store my first
comic book store was Katz's
confectionery in Hyland's New Jersey not
strictly a comic book store but they had
three spinner racks a kid's comics right
so that's where I bought Secret Wars
that's where I bought vision and the
Scarlet Witch actually I subscribed to
Marvel for vision and the Scarlet Witch
that's what I'm excited about Wanda
I thought that was so romantic I was
like she her boyfriend's a robot
what else did I get there remember when
they did the Marvel Universe handbook oh
yeah [ __ ] one of my favorite comics
of all time because they dad everybody
it wasn't a story it was just like this
[ __ ] and this is what he could
do and there's what she could do and
this are powers and this is the [ __ ]
team like I love that [ __ ] book so I
used to get all those they're my first
bona fide comic book store I would say
that Walt Flanagan took me to in circuit
19 I want to say late 88 early 89 was
the Hobby no [ __ ] what were they cup the
hobby shop in Matawan okay it's all the
way out Maui shop Hobby Lobby it wasn't
like that wasn't a thing I think it was
literally called the hobby shop it was
like a mama popjoy
right then I started going to Ray's
collectibles which was in middle town
near the high school then we went to I
mean we also went to fantasy Zone in
Middletown they're gone as well
no they were fantasy zone was in red bag
Middletown was comics plus I sold them
my comic book collection to make clerks
and then the last one was calm ecology
which we bought and that became Jay and
Silent Bob's secret stash in 1999 so the
stash is now 21 years old we've been in
a retail business for a minute as well I
you know I'm in a good space and as much
as if I was strictly accountable
retailer I would probably be thinking
about closed down let me tell you a
[ __ ] story man this is like just a
dopey story about you never [ __ ] know
so I called up I was talking to a wall
he's Lanigan well I got the store for in
the first place like you know one time
we were driving around like long before
I made clerks and he would come back
from a comic book shopping like we were
driving around this state try to find
comic book stores that we'd never been
to look for like [ __ ] copies The
Killing Joke that hadn't gone up on a
wall yet if you find some unsuspecting
small mom-and-pop shop you like oh [ __ ]
so we were driving home and you know I
was like this rocks [ __ ] comics right
and he was just like I always wanted to
run a comic book store and I was like
[ __ ] yeah man owned a comic book store
would be amazing he has not owned it
that's too much responsibility
he said I'd always wanted to run a comic
store cuz I could get a big discount in
my books and what a great job that would
be so you know years later after clerks
and mall rats and [ __ ] this opportunity
to take over a calm ecology came about
and it was very inexpensive relatively
speaking it was only double what I paid
to make clerks
so if clerks is twenty seven thousand
five hundred seventy five bucks comic
ology I could take it over for 60 grand
like that's all to contents the the
store the [ __ ] client list and you
know he's paying rent and [ __ ] for where
the place you're taking it over but I
was like for just double what I paid for
clerks Walter his dream could [ __ ]
come true so I was like you know what is
worth it and so I was told Steve Dave
the guy that a comic ology I'll do it
and then I told Walt
hey man [ __ ] I bought a Steve Dave
story we're gonna call Jason Bob Seger's
- you're gonna run it he's like no I'm
not
took me two years to convince him to
leave his job at the the Highlands
Recreation Center and run the store
full-time he was running from a distance
he'd order all our books and stuff like
that Brian was the front man Brian
Johnson but you know Walt knew that
world like crazy so the store was bought
for a wall he eventually came and he's
been there ever since and it's been open
all this time not because of me I'm
never [ __ ] there Walt Flanagan master
retailored [ __ ] Mike zapcic as well get
him you know they got a great crew
Johnny does the mail order and stuff so
I called up Walt to be like well a lot
of stores closing and we've had a great
run like over 20 years it's longer than
we ever imagined and [ __ ] and you know
who knows - does it bounce back and you
know you're to boot I told them I was
like you're the boots-on-the-ground guy
you're there every [ __ ] day
like if it was your money would you keep
it up but would you keep the secret
stash open or should we just close up
and he goes if it was my money he's gone
I'd keep it open this is really he goes
oh yeah I said I can only got the store
for you and you don't even collect
comics anymore and he goes yeah but the
store is bigger than me he's gone people
love this place it's like a living
organism he's gone and also he's gone
you got a lease until the end of the
year right he's gone just sooner or
later we'd get to open again if after a
few months nobody coming back then have
that conversation but like he said
something so pointing he goes I when I
closed the door the other day I didn't
think that was the last time I was ever
gonna close the door in the stash he's
gone like I always thought he's going do
you ever see the the end of Mary Tyler
Moore the last episode when like they
literally turned the lights off he was
like I I thought that's how the stash
would end he's gone so I would keep it
going and I was like [ __ ] a man as the
guy leaves likely I told them Walt
like [ __ ] I've known you almost 30
[ __ ] years and you continue to
surprise me I honestly thought he would
have been like Oh
like I'm done like this this is some
[ __ ] we did when we were kids like [ __ ]
this store I want to go back to a normal
life I play he's got like the patreon
tell him Steve Dave and stuff like that
so at the end of the day I thought he'd
be like yeah let it go but even he was
just like don't don't let it go man so
it's tough out there for retailers not
for me as particular I got the luxury of
being like all right we can weather this
storm because I got other jobs [ __ ] like
that for other retailers not so easy so
tonight ladies and gentlemen if you just
tuned in this is a fundraiser for Bank
what does Bank pink is the [ __ ]
foundation is a company that's helping
provide relief financial relief to
independent booksellers and more you
know pertaining our demographic comic
book stores yeah so yeah every donation
to them will find its way you know to a
comic book store that's in your life
that you know need some help
whoo we got another guest we got another
gas
we have we have car D'Angelo you got him
yeah we're getting car right now and
everybody be gettin gettin good at being
a little studio now I in the age of
covert like everybody like Seth Meyers
has to shoot his own show [ __ ] live to
our field team now Matt thanks we are
the only two that haven't really gotten
better at this [ __ ] cuz we got JC oh
yeah hey turn your youtube down they
used to say on the Howard Stern Show
there we go there we are
how are you car good how're you guys
doing so damn [ __ ] good man look at
this place it's hopping it's crazy
Friday night that was a great story you
just told about wall cuz that's a that's
how I feel too it's it's it's the shop
anybody who has comic book shop you know
this is it is bigger than you it's not
just about me it's not just about the
staff people have created a community
about their shop that is something that
you don't even you know you say you're
the owner but you don't even really own
it anymore they all own it this folks is
a car runs and owns what does it called
earth to comics earth to two locations
is one in Sherman Oaks and one in
Northridge and one you own with geoff
johns right yes how sweet like a gut you
know like you're rarely hear about
somebody gone I'm gonna like I'm gonna
go into the retail that most creatives
stay out of the retail end I think it's
cool that he went into that's neat man
okay so you are a real
honest-to-goodness dyed-in-the-wool
boots-on-the-ground
retailer tell us how you're feeling
right now is it a scary time you just
said wonderful words about you know hey
man it's bigger than us and [ __ ] but
like that only goes so far if you run
out of loot how you handling all this I
mean it is scary it is you know it is a
tough time you know we're doing our best
with you know we're in L
so you know there's you know this is
even one of the stricter kind of
lockdown communities so it's been very
tough because you know our doors aren't
open but what we've been trying to do is
you know again take care of using
reservists take care of all the
subscribers we've got their bullets if
they haven't been in for a month we
don't want them to have to wait a couple
more months so we're trying to get that
stuff to them but it's a it's a lot of
work for not what we do because we're
the kind of store where we looked at
people come in and browse and find
things that they wouldn't normally buy
and we stopped your restock deep we're
not just you know we order subscription
copies plus ones for the shelf
we have stacks of ten or twenty because
we really want to you know make
recommendations and get people excited
about you know certain books so it's
really hard when you can't do that kind
of a hand selling now did you read about
like DC or we just had Jim on he's going
hey man in April we're getting books out
into retailers hands again and stuff
like that is that a welcome relief or is
it a band-aid like I mean it's all kinda
tricky because I mean diamond also
released a statement today how they're
aiming for sort of mid-may to get their
their wheels running again I think
that's kind of a that's kind of a
schedule that's more on par with what a
lot of the with what's going on around
the country I think most people expect
to be open more in mid May or end in May
so you know the DC news it came down
today it's a lot to swallow but it's
hard there's a lot to think about there
because it's not a it is a new startup
type of thing so it's also asking a lot
of from retailers we kind of want a
certainty and being told to go to some
new distributors that we haven't worked
with before
it's kind of a you know we need more
stability than uncertainty so you know
it's it's it's it's a step but you know
I'm interested to see where all those
sweet sweet yeah so and how are you
personally doing I mean how what is it
like being an independent sort of
businessman in a world in which you
can't do your independent business you
know how is how's your mindset how's
your family you know how have you get to
interact with your customers very much
and find out how their
well I used to say wow it would be great
if like the store was closed for a bit
so I could process all those back issues
that have been building well I guess I
should not have I should not have wished
for that because like I'm in my office
right now and if I turned the camera
you'd see about at nine boxes nine short
boxes a back issue so I'm trying to prep
and get stuff priced and keep working
that way one of my managers is handling
a lot of the mail order stuff what I'm
doing I'm doing like the customer
communication invoicing you know getting
paid through PayPal and then giving him
the list of these are the things you
know we can send out but it's it's you
know we started on Facebook in addition
to having Facebook pages we also started
a community earth soup comics community
so that our regulars and our subscribers
could kind of interact and you know just
sort of be able to keep in touch so when
we have something to announce you know
again when everybody that's the question
everyone's asking when are new comics
going to be released again so when I
have some news I take it there I let
them know what's going on no diamond put
like the previews catalog online for
free normally you have to buy it's we're
gonna buy that phone book for four bucks
they put it on online for free so we
wanted to let everybody know that so at
least while they're home they could flip
through and let us know what they want
to order in the future and try and keep
try and keep the old habits you know
going no doubt man like cuz when
everything goes that's what people I
think are going like like it was Walt's
point when I was talking to Walt about
closing it because I was like is anybody
gonna care like after all this like this
is a world [ __ ] changing event and
even if they do care does anybody have
any money a lot of people out of work
and we're not selling anything [ __ ]
essential it's all like fun stuff and
whatnot but Walt's point was I think
people are going to [ __ ] crave
normalcy crave going back to routines
and yes like the world's been upended
and stuff and some things will never go
back to quote-unquote normal but running
a retail shop look you know it's not
like a comic book store is not like
running a [ __ ] concert hall where
it's like man if we don't have 2000
bodies in here how are we gonna pay for
this and stuff
comic store you can like are you come in
now you go out and stuff like that
so maybe when we all get to come back
out there are a bunch of people who are
just like I this will make me feel
normal again this is my comfort food
like this is like the thing that I shape
my identity around so I'm going to the
store
maybe I mean I know I've seen like a lot
of dire prognostications online but I
feel like it might also work in another
direction where people are like I've
missed you for so long I've missed my
retail establishment like Mark asked a
great question which I'd never even
thought of when he was like how are you
doing with your clients like just the
people that come into the [ __ ] store
the relationships that you build you're
like [ __ ] Sam Malone for Christ's
sakes and Cheers
like what is norm and cliff doing right
now talking to people and again wanting
you know what one you know great story
is I got an email out of the blue from a
guy who said hey do you have saga volume
5 through 9 and when I looked him up in
our system he brought volumes 1 through
4 about three years ago I got it anybody
came to us and that was the really like
nice thing didn't you didn't go to
Amazon you didn't go to you know a big
mail-order place and said hey these a
lot of people will say if you introduced
me to something that I love I want to I
want to follow that with you you know if
I started reading Batman or saga or
whatever with you guys I'm gonna always
come back to you guys you know for that
so there is that that customer contact
that really does have to be maintained
they trust you give them some good once
yeah you know they're like I like that
you give them twice man you got him for
life and [ __ ] when before the pandemic
how were you guys doing as a retail
establishment it was you know the
beginning of this year was very tricky
um you know part of it is there's always
a there's always an issue sort of with
the publishers you know they never
really launched like the big except for
like the one time a couple years ago
Marvel did Star Wars number one when
they relaunched Star Wars now January
great those that was really in its Star
Wars what's you know what's what's not
Comics that's bigger than Star Wars
right so you put those two things
together and it was a monster and it got
people coming in who hadn't been into
the comic shop for a while and but
normally the publishers kind of take
January and February off anyway so
there's not the big events there's not
the big product a lot of stuff kind of
wrapped up at the end of the year like
Doomsday Clock and things like that that
were the big events people were
following so it had been kind of a
quieter time and I think for us too in
February again a lot of the you know in
Los Angeles a lot of the social
distancing talk and all of that really
kind of started mid to end fabric
beginning of March and it kind of you
know we we kind of saw a slowdown kind
of being beginning but again as you say
we there's always there's always
something you know you know coming out
later that's gonna be it's going to be
exciting you're just different ways to
get your get your customers excited get
fans back in the store you can always
wait it out we've been through a lot of
ups and downs and we've always been able
to wait you know wait things out but
this is kind of tricky because it is
it's you know everybody but I do agree
with you Kevin that maybe keeping people
from the shop might create hopefully
creates a lot of interest once shops are
open and once the material is released
again and I think that's why a lot shops
I wanted kind of a uniformity of how the
comments get released because I think
it's better a sort of like a big event
you know like the way I think they
announced that they're holding back that
you know it was Jim said they're holding
back Batman 92 because you want to make
sure everybody can get that book at the
same time because it's been so
anticipated the beginning of Joker war
and all of that you don't want to just
you know oh you know some stores are
going to have it and in April and I've
accrued are gonna have it in a so it
makes sense to kind of let them I meant
can build for that you talk to he had a
really good example of how the cat
ordered saga from you as opposed to
gonna Amazon and stuff it's one way to
help out earth to end or your local
comic book store what are other ways
that folks who you know and again we're
not gilding anybody if you can help help
but
if you're passionate about the field if
you're passionate about the the milieu
of comic books and comic book stores
what can they be doing right now to help
out you guys one of the things I've been
saying is is you know is buy a gift
certificate because that's like the
easiest low-impact things for us right
now so if you know it's a store you're
gonna go back to you know you know if
you don't know exactly what you here's a
book you want you know they haven't
great order that book will mail order it
to you but a lot of times a lot of
stores you can people gift certificate
so call up and say I want a $10 $20 gift
certificate if you don't want to ever
use it if you want to make it a donation
you can do that or it's just going to be
there waiting for you when the store
opens you know the thing not to do is to
call and say oh this is finally the time
I'm going to find out if you have that
random issue of champions 1975 and if
you have that I'll buy it from you then
you're making me run around for two you
know looking for a three dollar book and
you're not doing me any favors but you
know but I think the things are just
trying to you know again reach out say
hi you know and you know like you saying
this is something like you know hey I
know they're gonna have I know they're
gonna have long Halloween I know they're
gonna have Killing Joke and I know
they're gonna have saw the or something
like that maybe they can send me a copy
that because I want to read that again
but if it's something you just want to
kind of dominate or help out if you're
calling or emailing and asking about it
is the easiest thing to do sweet man
excellent advice yeah I I have known car
for a long time for a very long time I
am curious misses nothing about comics
I'm just curious to hear your version of
how we got to know each other because
I'm sure it's a little different than
mine and so and we've never talked about
you know from your perspective the first
time we met our history and how it has
sort of evolved over the years
oh my god now I'm scared I'm afraid that
I insulted you or just you wait buddy
yeah
I remember when we both worked for
starlight magazine we did yes so Darla
you both worked for Starlog yeah he was
he was like two generation who's two
classes ahead of iterating oh [ __ ] he
was two classes ahead of me I was I was
a junior when he was already graduated
that's right that's and everybody who
got my job after me went to work for DC
Comics and and I was always very new
exam a letter from Paul Levitz where he
where he said we're not hiring right now
and so I left New York and then
everybody who worked there had my job
after me
worked for DC Comics it set marquee then
I think what do entertaining weekly or
whatever yeah but speak bona fides man
to be able to say you worked Starlog for
I know like and when I got there that
was that was always the narrative was
that everybody who works here goes to
work for DC Comics except for cardi
Angelo who went to Hollywood what I
remember was like a San Diego I forget
how we got we must have swap numbers or
something but we met up or granted to
each other or set something up at San
Diego I thought and the first time we
kind of really met face to face was you
know we we get like drinks or something
at some hotel was very romantic was like
a hotel I think it was it was like the
top of the Hyatt or something yeah
exactly but I also think it was either
before that are just after that because
he was an executive at Universal and
yeah I was I was a young wannabe
screenwriter and I was like I got an in
I know a guy
he works for Universal I'm gonna have a
meeting in his office and I went and had
a meeting in his office and nothing ever
came of it except you sent me I want to
say the script for reality bites and you
were like greet this and I did what do
you think I'm like I think this is
probably good he says yeah we do too and
that was the end of it uh-huh Wow
mark barnard got reality bites greenlit
that's where I hear that story
it's pretty amazing ben stiller [ __ ]
hold you and then like I'm like you know
jockey and I doing my [ __ ] back in the
air like some day man I'm gonna go back
and pitch car how am I getting to buy
something it is like I gave up on
Hollywood I'm opening a comic book store
walked away from [ __ ] Hollywood that
tells your story that tells you right
there
Smart Play car how's it been how's it
felt to be retail how many years now you
retail 17 you know so 2003 we open yeah
I think you hadn't read the story you
had the store in Westwood back then -
yeah yeah we were there for how long
we'll be there a couple years but ours
back home
it turned 20 when we were doing the show
we opened in 90 late 97 so at the end of
this year December this year will be 23
years and it's but that's not me I
haven't run it for 23 years Walt did all
that stuff but having a store is
incredible currency in the culture just
like being from New Jersey has been
incredible currency in the culture
having like oh yeah we got a
brick-and-mortar store man like it's and
as you know it's not as easy to keep a
comic book concern going you've done it
for nearly twenty years man
like what are you gonna do for the 20th
what's the anniversary would look like I
mean we'll do you know one of the things
actually the next year I want to make a
big deal because it's actually like the
anniversary like the 60th anniversary of
slash discovering Earth - in the comics
it happened in 1961 so so it battled
sorted so on that day I want to
celebrate I have so that I wasn't even
thinking at about 2023 good gosh
but yeah I mean you know a lot of my
friends who Brian field Brian heads up
in you know I mean you know a lot of
guys I know we've been having stores for
30 years Joe field in Concord
they they're having a 30th anniversary
and it's like wow so so yeah I mean
we'll do something big I mean we always
like to
you know again big events big sales and
I think that's one of the things that's
going to impact us as well is you're
saying we might have to be like it one
person at a time in the store but part
of the fun of having a store is when you
have you know we've had Julie at the
sign at the store but it was also was
under the guise of also selling his
daughter's Girl Scout cookie so it was a
fun day it was really it was really it
was really bring people together to buy
Girl Scout cookies but you know you have
a big event like that but that's that's
more what I'm concerned about is it's
not having I hope in 2023 I'll be able
to have a really huge 20th anniversary
event because you know we've done we do
like 10 sales in the back and stuff like
that and it would be kind of a thing of
really wanting to have not just a sale
but have a party have guests have the
people who you know some of the people
who've really supported the shop over
the years you know we're lucky to be in
Los Angeles and have those you have
those visitors you know like you know
Kirkman and people like that who pass
through all the time just because this
is where you know you know you know I
obviously you know seeing the store and
seeing the business from from 2003 the
great part has been is seeing how you're
the Marvel you know the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and you have the geeks
inherited the earth and really took over
and so many of those guys the
showrunners the producers you know we're
you know it's you don't have to hide
your you know you know used to be able
to go no I'm not reading a comic book
you know don't make fun of me or
whatever it was a bit like that where I
grew up and and you know and then if
it's now it's become a thing of like oh
you're reading comic books that's really
cool and that's been a great thing to
say so damn true dandak car you think
you helped with that you helped a lot
with that Kevin so thank you you're too
sweet man I love when people like hey
man you've [ __ ] helped him like not
and I just I'd literally talked about
[ __ ] that I loved it was it wasn't even
like I want to help the community it was
it was not altruistic it was like I love
this [ __ ] and honestly I can't talk
about anything else I tried talking to
me about politics car hit balls [ __ ]
a park but like you see my face lit up I
was like 19
see one is the anniversary of because he
holds up a newspaper Barry Allen holds
up a newspaper in Keystone City it it
has the exact date that is fantastic
alright man well thank you for taking
the time car you got anything else for
car
I do not man just uh you know stay safe
I hope you guys can keep the lights on
when we're all on the other side of this
because you know I like a store that I
can drop in and I know the guy and if
you want to help out car on earth to
either locations hit the website up get
one of the gift certificates man yeah
and like if those aren't the stores near
you if you've got a different store then
I think ours advice is sound all across
the board
yeah gift certificate you know buy you
know ten fifteen twenty bucks buy a
couple of comments for yourself in the
future today like the man said thank you
car thank you alright be good great
seeing you
look at that man we did like two [ __ ]
guests we were like man I feel like
Regis nuts stay tuned for the
replacements talking about comics we got
news don't we we got some news man why I
come to the [ __ ] show I loved our
guests they were informative his [ __ ]
but I come to learn about the news some
[ __ ] I know when we come in some [ __ ] I
don't so it's always fun for me and
stuff mark barnard in' is an old news
hound and even though he's become big
shock creative the news instincts nose
for news it never goes away ladies and
gentlemen Mark Bernard hunted down some
news first give it up for Mark Bernard
news and news before you dive into your
news can I do little news you wanna do
some news do it here in Los Angeles on
tomorrow not tomorrow Sunday starting
Sunday 419 and going to 426 of April 20
April 19 is April 26 through post mates
you could order movies we're doing a
movies pop up when we're allowed to open
back up the world and stuff with the
good folks that did saved by the max
they did the good burger restaurant so
they take a restaurant make it look like
a restaurant they do McDowell's they I
don't know
McDowell's I'll find out but they've
done it's that sort of thing right so
they're gonna do movies as well so in
the midst of all this pandemic and
whatnot they came up with a really cool
idea like we're gonna do these movie
meals like you know like it looks like a
[ __ ] fun you know fun what do they
call it happy and it's got fun eats yeah
a good time put [ __ ] in your mouth box
well really just blanked unhappy meal
tells you two things there are two words
that I'm not familiar with any more
happy and meal because all I do is eat
[ __ ] potato chips and read the news
going like [ __ ] I mean at least they're
vegan potato chips about a reformed fat
kid who's just like happy meals lost
heart attack no more happy meals unhappy
meals for the rest of my life cuz of
vegan so we're doing speaking of vegan
both happy both movies man packing those
both movie meals you could do vegan
style you could do not be itself they're
doing a lasagna which movies messy
lasagna which which is lasagna on bread
it's delicious they're doing an order of
hater tots which are just tater tots and
but named in honor of Jay and Silent Bob
reboot and it comes to chocolate covered
pretzels either vegan or non-vegan nice
really cool also comes a little signed
cab autograph the news was met very well
this week we're donating all the money
that we raised to know us without you
which is a charity that feeds people
that you know in the midst of the
pandemic so you know is a nice thing if
you're doing it you know because you
don't have to be ordering off post mates
and [ __ ] but if you are and you're like
I can't cook and [ __ ] for a week
including on 4/20 which is Monday
you can literally order some movies
there's limited supply that once they're
gone they're gone each one has a little
keV autograph in and [ __ ] like that
but it's the response has been so well
is they've there has been I know a
[ __ ] few people there has been talked
about doing it beyond Los Angeles so if
your post Maidan in other parts of this
great country of ours and you're like
I want to be in on that hold that
thought
because you know it seems like we're
gonna be indoors for a long time so this
is a moveable feast so we'll let you
know more but as of Sunday order movie
meals off post Bates man it could be a
good time and then order one and have it
sitting there on 4/20 because on 4/20
hmm which is my people's [ __ ] holiday
we're gonna do Mallrats watch along on
Facebook focus the good folks at focus
are putting together these screenings
free screenings where people do watch
alongs and stuff I think like somebody
way better than me did it like last week
like [ __ ] Wes Anderson for some says
[ __ ] I somebody's like real legit but
they reach out to me and they were like
you made Mallrats right I was like [ __ ]
ya made Mallrats I'm writing a sequel
right now so we're gonna do a Mallrats
watch long it'll be a good time I'm you
don't see me I think I'm typing mm-hmm
from what I understand but yeah that
starts tomorrow night I think it's like
7 o'clock or something you look for
details online get your movies mail from
post Bates if you're in Los Angeles if
you're everywhere else 4:20 Mallrats
watch along now that's my news yes let
me ask you a question
is there and if there is not there
should be a 4/20 parade well not this
year mark okay clearly not I don't know
if you're familiar what's going on in
the world and I don't know if you've
seen these gloves but yeah no I've never
seen it there should be I mean because
not for nothing
they're like I I'm imagining lots of
floats covered in green I'm imagining
you as a grand marshal of this
[ __ ] every year every year and
then like you know Snoop is the emcee
and like there's there's enough if
there's a to thank you for your kindness
but it should be two grand marshals I'll
go I just put me on any foods give me a
float like it seems as if that's kind of
a late-in-life stoners like I'm on that
Betty White should be a [ __ ] stoner
parade you're right one of the first
things where you get to work on when all
this [ __ ] pandemic is over stoner
parade for 2021 ladies and gentlemen
sadly for 2020
yeah not gonna happen before 2021 mark
Barnard and stoner play parade and
really what's that what we're raising
money for tonight ladies and gentlemen
Mark Barnard stumped RIT no we're
raising money for the good folks at Bank
what is it called Inc foundation big
foundation was the stand for
I don't really know money as was Danny's
money that goes to small bookstore
owners but we're doing it for the comic
book folds material indeed and right now
if we look at the old tow port well look
at that oh it's up to 13 20 words in 45
we just got another 20 bucks we're over
halfway to our goal tonight it's $20
from Phil Rizzuto from the Money Store
do you see can you see names come I was
like Phil rasam Phil Rizzuto from the
money store hello welcome to Cal Phil my
name is Tom Tom Wednesday is Sunday at
Carvel the kid said you like he does he
like fudgie the whale I've got a fudgy
cake just for him and what was the end
cookie puss
and cookie for the hottest [ __ ] ice
cream cake on the planet every boy
wanted cookie puss Tom Carvel man that's
the days of like I'm the guy that owns
the company and they've made me [ __ ]
talk about it in a commercial that's
over nobody would ever do that [ __ ]
again I'd be like get somebody and hire
a Tom Carvel this guy sounds like he's
disinterested in his ice cream cuz he
did oh he was he was like a change
smoking like Detroit business it wasn't
like [ __ ] like hey kids you like ice
cream it was boiling when's this son
dead Carvel am I done I don't want to
talk about this [ __ ] today is Presidents
Day
and so we just put a hat on cookie puss
because now he's George Washington
cookie feels a sharp rock as well didn't
budge you the whale became something
else but the commercial like was always
so like if you were in the food it was
food porn cuz look look at us pouring
the ice cream in this mold and [ __ ] he's
gonna be like oh but then you would have
this guy going
Carmel ice cream is so good
come the Cavell and they never showed
him probably no yes it was always just
like glory shots of the [ __ ] food
money shots of the food the most like in
Congress voice ever if he was still
around they should have guys you see
that offer they offered the one guy the
sports dude a million bucks to do the
play-by-play on some cam girls a porn up
or something like that and he was like I
don't know what his name is Jacques
something I don't stralla sports but in
any event other people were like like I
saw Ralph tweeted he's like I'll do it
but we could get if he was alive if only
Tom Carvel did be like all right they're
[ __ ] now what is this was the pooper
what the hell Wednesday is Sunday and
even like if you get back ok Jenna she's
a flipping the other girl upside down
and things are happening here I'm not
sure what I think that might be a cookie
puss but it's not made of cookie I've
never felt dirtier saying the word
cookie puss yeah that was the same era
of crazy Eddie
the prices are insane one of the
greatest salesman of our lifetime and
sure I know there's some scandals
arriving you're surrounding him or some
say [ __ ] but like those commercials were
delightful and nobody does that [ __ ]
anymore either no they were so low rent
and so easy guy just screaming at the
guy on the camera crazy our brothers are
insane remember they were do the lineup
a [ __ ] like in Manhattan the Bronx I
acid they listed [ __ ] names of places
in like Syosset where the [ __ ] is that
when I was on the J and saw Bob reboot
row show doing [ __ ] went through sigh
off I was like I've heard of you crazy
any new you the border of Nassau and
Suffolk County is it yes you've been
there I have there was a really great
movie theater in Syosset [ __ ] what else
goes on inside not very much at all
sounds like such like a New York outside
Manhattan yeah it's out is it Long
Island Long Island yeah it sounds like
such a long I am like what Patchogue
yeah it's a assets like Long Island was
where they let the Indian places retain
their identity as well as New Jersey
where they just made everything
Cherry Hill you wait a second you mean
Cherry Hill is not American
I'm pretty sure the Iroquois did not
know I come from Highlands that sounds
like it could totally be it it gave
American Li Matawan might still be an
Indian name for all I know but
Middletown less so I mean you know
that's like I mean that's like every
towns got every every states got a
middle town but I think it's funny
you're like they took it all and they
changed every [ __ ] name you're like
well not me I want not matter and
probably not this one and you know what
literally it's like this this way like
Oh Copiague you know Massapequa
Massapequa all right yeah way news
Mark's got real news I got real news
like we're doing crazy Eddy news people
like isn't coming back I mean the first
item is I think the item that we all
knew was a going to happen because we
talked about last time are we gonna open
with the bad news can we do all the
happy news first and then the big news
here comes lemons tighten your [ __ ]
get your sphincters good and tight
because something you're about to hear
something nobody wanted to hear but we
all knew we were gonna hear anyway say
it because I don't want to say it
because they hate the messenger go ahead
Mark's got to tell you something really
[ __ ] horrible Comic Con 20/20 has
officially been canceled what let's get
mark barnard in everybody he cancelled
Comic Con yeah this I mean here's what
I've been thinking I've ran into a kid I
was in Ralph's like two weeks ago and
you know because the this show because
like I don't know for the last 25 years
I've been like oh my comic books he was
just like hey man is Comic Con gonna
happen this year like I was you know a
foremost security and I was right here
to the ground son tell me about comic
kinda and I was like oh come on that
could how could it not happen I was like
that's too big too it's too big to
cancel such a big fan and apparently
like South by Southwest was like we're
too big to cancel Comic Cons like hold
my beer yeah they're going away for the
year they've said they won't be back
till 2021 the first time in 50 years 50
years there won't be a Comic Con now you
know we're in history right here that's
what I'm telling you like how does every
[ __ ] thing that's
from now on that's set in the present
not like some period piece not reference
this like it's so [ __ ] massive
you have to it's got to show up in the
comic books yeah I mean it'll be like
this markers of 2020 will be but like
kovat pandemic and vaping that's how
you'll know exactly when you were in
time it's like all these douchebags
vaping oh that's right that was right
around the time everyone started getting
hey man you might have just found a link
between those two things just saying
let's not be specious we have no
scientific information we're two guys
wearing gloves in a bar you know some
places that makes a scientist sure we
are not any or not we trust trust me I
am a doctor though but not of Medicine I
got one of those honorary doctorates
nice can you prescribe subscribe advice
what the [ __ ] are we gonna do in July
mark that was my beginning of the
calendar year hmm that's like that's you
know fiscal year day one exactly thank
you very much it makes sense of course I
was thinking about it after I talked to
that kid in the inter alfe's and so some
assuredly [ __ ] told him that it was
happening in [ __ ] but it's like even if
they were like open the doors in the
country and mid-may let's say June like
you know that's that's a yeah seems like
an expense eeeem like the attendance was
gonna be way low anyway if they even
allowed it to happen cuz right now
they're still not saying yeah let's cram
[ __ ] you know 200,000 people into a
space real close and [ __ ] so like the
governor has already pretty much said
that like California will not be open to
like large gatherings concerts
conventions you know they're still even
debating movie theaters but they're
there they're not going to like open it
like professional sports like no we've
got it I'm not gonna cram 45:5 he might
be in the right space cuz they I'm under
like you know this bloke what 50 people
you think we can yeah like spaced out no
I think I figured out we could do about
40 people spaced out we could open and
be spaced out six feet forty people
that's a [ __ ] show
that is a show that is an audience I've
done to some less than that yeah you me
both sometimes to a dog that's my show
I'm like your watch hey guys I got your
food food here listen to my monologue
yeah so the event will be what a bummer
it'll return I grabbed Thor's hammer
what a bummer
there will be no Comic Con but it makes
sense yeah it's coming back July 22nd of
2021
whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo one year and a half
away yay what is it April we're about to
be May June July so it's only a year and
three months away right and some
WonderCon which was similarly postponed
and it was supposed to be this coming
weekend it was supposed to be tonight
WonderCon WonderCon was supposed to
start no that's an April 10th I don't
know what well what is time it's month
Timbre yeah and it's a question question
mark day so wait a second is the New
York Comic Con that's in the fall right
New York Comic Con it's October Haven
can see that may have been canceled yet
you know and and there's a [ __ ]
cancel the whole year has been canceled
essentially yeah and then you know movie
theaters are started talking about like
a limited opening I saw the President of
the United States mentioned that limited
movie theaters would be one of the first
things and I was like is anybody didn't
they do that in China they opened up the
movie theaters and nobody went yeah
because that's gonna be the thing is
that you know a people are definitely
afraid of a second wave and if you do
this too fast that's precisely what
you're gonna get and be I think there's
just this this sudden distrust of people
and germs and gatherings that like even
if you opened the world the way the
president wants to who's gonna go what
if you throw in the earth and nobody
shows up I look I want I would love to
go out as much as the next person but
I'm like and I'm gonna wait until yeah I
got nothing impressing in a world where
they canceled Comic Con my ears over so
I'm happy to sit home until I'm told I'm
here once a weekend I'm fine go out and
play
I've been preparing for this my life I'm
an introvert yeah but Florida like
Florida's reopening their beaches I
think as soon as they can and it's like
guys why I don't know for the money this
is straight out of Jaws it's all this
this whole pandemics has revealed a lot
of mayor bonds out there we're like
Amity is a summer town we need summer
dollars ya know I mean and it's it's
across the board we're getting to see
who the morons are I think you say
Barracuda it was uh what'd you say shark
you got a panic on your hands on the 4th
of July this is an entire year of 4th of
July everybody who does that sort of
like ah like to see the video of the
dude in Wisconsin who was completely
covered head to toe he's like it's
completely safe to vote that was people
anyone who they should be forced to wear
the anchor jacket that Mayor Vaughn in
Jaws war I guess they hang him up by his
Buster Brown's alright so Comic Cons not
happening but I'm sure a bunch of people
like I put out a tweet where I was like
come to my house all the [ __ ] Comic
Con for you I'm sure there'll be lots of
streaming I'm doing a streaming con very
very soon
online the name of which escapes me JC
can you look it up real quick
virtual con is it that it's a virtual
con on line it's coming up I forget but
maybe there'll be yeah let's put a
[ __ ] camera on JC so he's like
nervously like I don't know what the
[ __ ] he's talking about pressures our
[ __ ] he said search and he's
really hanging you out to dry I'm not
sure like one of those guys in 24 like
Jack Bauer standing over his shoulder
he's trying to open a socket
he's like I'm trying to do it the bombs
gonna go I'm trying your max and [ __ ]
homeland have you been watching a
homeland I haven't watched homeland
since season 1 [ __ ] dude jump on board
it's the last season great is it it's
been really great particular still
awesome I'm aw he's fantastic no she's
great whole [ __ ] thing's great
I'm also [ __ ] fully in on little
fires everywhere but that girl who
played Harry Washington yeah it was
you got real Kerry washed it which is
fun - but that's worth a watch
alright man what do we know what it's
called did you figure that is it the
virtual pop Expo May 9th and 10th maybe
we're doing a May before are you done is
the one day 24 hour that [ __ ] right here
you know hear it though just did yeah
give me another camera now it's take
your mask down and announce that we're
gonna do a cuz may the fourth obviously
it's a big nerd holiday we're gonna do a
24 hour stream I think you guys are
gonna do a little Empire Strikes Back
commentary oh yes I cut to us hell yes
cut back to Jersey
the black man beyond guest host Todd
stashwick and I are going to do a new
hope earlier in the day and you'll have
lots to say because you were on set when
they made that movie is that correct
[Laughter]
that's awesome so it's a live streaming
May the fourth event on what the scum
and villainy Jen the scum and villainy
channel we've got some other stuff that
I probably can't announce yet from some
really big collectible retailers we're
gonna reveal some products and hopefully
we're gonna do some stuff with Clone
Wars actors a lot of really good Star
Wars content and I'm hoping that we can
open the bar for drive up blue milk
service oh how awesome would that be you
pull up are gonna give you a blue milk
you [ __ ] off on right on Hollywood right
on Hollywood
we're gonna have let me tell you
something there's no [ __ ] traffic
like any other time I Billy you're
[ __ ] nuts but now I'm like oh my god
let's open up our house on [ __ ] land
a plane
it's Harrison Ford lying on Hollywood
Boulevard that's such a good idea man
drive a blue milk it's awesome eleven
dollars and 38 cents you'll get blue
milk why 11:38 Oh George Lucas's thx 1-1
3-8
scum and villainy swag just like a
little happy meal type May before
everybody's doing it boss
that's fantastic good for you and that
is for made the fourth made the fourth
keep an eye out ladies again meanwhile
what is our tote board up to 14 gonna be
fun
85 nice 10 bucks away from 1,500 what do
we got to do to get to 1,500 you want
him to put it on put him on the glass
we'll both put him on the glass bring us
a spit guard what are the news we got
now at Comic Con is not happening so the
gonna guess what kids for the first time
and you're privileged little t-ball
lives you're not gonna get to do what
you want to do in July dad sucks I know
I feel like it's been put off there
rolling we had exclusive pops that we
were releasing a comedy jerk
yes so in my first world everything's
fun man that's a bummer but we're living
in history kids we are if you've ever
been one of those [ __ ] it's like man
nothing ever happened in my lifetime
welcome yeah welcome to your burgess
meredith moment I would like less things
to happen in my life yeah no nothing
else for the object a slow easy ride
right to the grave please full up yeah
too many things Babbitt in my lifetime
yeah
what let's move on to greener pastures
since we're not a we passed over we
danced in 1595 they want to see you put
them on a glass oh [ __ ] 100 bucks just
in a clip what we can't talk about
comic-con anymore cos it's so sad but
understandable and sometimes sad things
have to be understood kids you have to
understand them that's part of being an
adult sometimes bad things happen to
good people
yeah yeah sometimes hey guys Donny Cates
just donate
a hundred bucks I don't know [ __ ] a
man what for you donning Kate's he wants
you to put him on a glass put him right
up I took a page out of if you came in
late to the show at a Donnie Cates book
he paid for all the folks in Austin at
the comic book store he goes to for
their reserve books for this month and
stuff and he said hey just use the money
in the store to buy cool things that you
would have not bought for yourself
before I said what a cool idea so I
called Mike zapcic at the secret stash
in Jersey I said empty the reserve box
send it out some Mike's now sending all
the reservists books out to those cats
and stuff see man you see somebody as a
good idea you [ __ ] steal it you steal
it you milk it I think we we might have
flirted with this before but HBO max
just ordered three television programs
from JJ Abrams and bad robot this news
was so [ __ ] exciting to me put a pin
in it real quick yeah what did I want JC
Oh before we go further give yourself a
single what happened on Clone Wars
okay so spoilers because somebody
spoiled this for me so if you don't want
to know but cover your ears one two
three here come the spoilers they
started the new episode of Clone Wars
with black screen with the neon green
old-school Lucasfilm limited production
logo like was on the Star Wars movies we
grew ones before they changed it for the
special edition and immediately just
told you like oh this is gonna this is
gonna kick you in the gut this is a
little time machine are they doing the
siege at Mandalore siege of Mandalore
that's the storyline this which ties in
oddly to this episode mandala references
also it ties into the beginning of
Revenge of the Sith really this story
that you will watch on Clone Wars this
week happens concurrently with the
opening of Revenge of the Sith
really so they're saying ahsoka was
around wait Revenge of the Sith isn't
that where they do order 66 order 66 so
with the
getting of this at the beginning of this
episode they're like you know the Jedi
are spread out and you see each of the
Jedi that die arriving on the planet
that they will be executed on are you
[ __ ] me it's amazing that's Dave
Filoni as fellow knee man don't you love
it when people do their job well that is
some deep science that's [ __ ] cool
man that's cool to hear um alright so
I'm gonna go watch that when I get home
alright back to this [ __ ] exciting
news because yes the Justice League dark
[ __ ] is fantastic and we talked to Jim
about it earlier if you're jumping in
now Jim Lee was on earlier and we talked
about Justice League dark the one I want
to talk about yes the one that I think
is [ __ ] brilliant and I'm like how to
[ __ ] did nobody do this before yes is
Overlook Hotel mm nah it's [ __ ]
brilliant they're doing a show called
the Overlook Hotel which is essentially
[ __ ] what a series of like this bad
thing happened this bad thing happened
nothing about you know two shining which
is all the horrible [ __ ] that happened
in the [ __ ] hotels that what am i
right according to the sort of press
release it explores the untold
terrifying stories of the most famous
haunted hotel in American fiction this
is a great idea I know I said that about
dr. sleep I'm gonna say it about this
this is a great idea it's like it's
lends itself to an anthology this is
very smart coming from the guy that did
castle rock yes dusty Thomason who was
my boss on Castle Rock along with Scott
Brown who was my assistant at
Entertainment Weekly 100% I [ __ ] love
this I know that dude's name for men or
- yeah he was my assistant I told that
story but he is he was the co EP on the
second season of Castle Rock right so
now he and dusty are staying in the
Stephen King's Own and checking into the
lunch a good idea yeah very excited for
them I I think that's I remember when we
first heard of Castle Rock we were all
like holy [ __ ] it's gonna be every
[ __ ] Steve against the Avengers
endgame of Stephen King characters and
that clearly wasn't the case but it was
more inspired by became his own thing
that won awards a [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
correct this though has the chance to
just be I just want just give me a
different [ __ ] horse tour
every week don't holler don't give me
any [ __ ] mythology you don't [ __ ]
like I work here [ __ ] you I just want to
I mean they could be some people working
there but I just want to see week after
week here's a [ __ ] it could be black
mirror [ __ ] that [ __ ] show could be
black mirror with a Stephen King [ __ ]
pedigree oh I'm so excited
don't you want to hear greedy story yes
the bartender who clearly killed a bunch
of [ __ ] people at some Grady
he was the caretaker I would like to
hear the story of Lloyd your ghostly
bartender he was the boy to tear the dog
the bit me Lloyd err the dog there's
that's just like like if you're doing
what 10 episodes you save those two
[ __ ] for like the end man but like
you could just go hog crazy it's such a
good idea who gets to play young Scatman
Crothers do
that's right dick oh hollering is good
you got the shot got eat yo melee you
want to be regular well we saw somebody
play us Scatman Crothers in dr. sleep oh
yeah I didn't I never said that Carl I
think is our guys yeah and may well The
O'Jays Paul also the Martian man
and on Supergirl the Martian Manhunter
is dead mm-hmm this is a good idea
what's the third show the third show is
a show called duster which was
co-written by JJ himself who doesn't do
what Tennant whoa oh yeah he doesn't do
that doesn't do a ton of that and LaToya
Morgan who was one of my co-hosts on a
black man beyond he's yet me yeah did
you know she was getting a show I knew
she was like developing a thing but as
is the bad robot way everything is a
secret until it's everything's a [ __ ]
mystery box yeah Jeezy crazy but
apparently it invites it in the 1970
Southwest revolves her on the life of a
gutsy getaway driver for a growing crime
syndicate what year 1970s I was born
then yes more than 70 so this is of
interest to me were you that man yeah
yeah child get away that's how I like
entertainment that's set in the past or
period [ __ ] cuz I'm like oh I I was I
was alive for those eras therefore that
like I think I what was it an infinity
war when they go to New Jersey
in 1970 I was like I was alive like
these [ __ ] this is history now I know
where that was all right so three
wonderful shows JJ off and running it
with as Warner Brothers deal yeah for
sure many more that of those things to
come and as happy as I am about Justice
League dark
I think [ __ ] overlooked the moment I
saw that imprint and this I ain't trying
I'm not like hire me not at all I look
forward to watching the [ __ ] out it's
just such a good idea
ya know it's a please be the show I want
it to be please just make it anthology
don't don't is Castle Rock they were all
connected right there's a story yes
don't know that you don't want that just
make it just every week it's a one-off
like black mirror and it's just you know
overlooked that's smart money right
there but then again I am the man that
made yo Gosar's take it with a grain of
salt I will I will do my best to convey
that to the gents I was telling the
public as if they were gonna help that's
right tonight hey this is the show Kevin
wants a cool
I remember like I thought like a lot of
people like Castle Rock was gonna be
like oh and then [ __ ] Cujo is gonna
show up he's gonna jump out of carry
nice hair crispy things if you Joe
jumped out of carry that's a [ __ ]
show everyone want to say yes he would
jump out of Christine like remember the
commercial for that one movie I think it
was Stephen King cat's-eye yes and it
was everything was little reference to a
Stephen King movie so there was like the
cat almost got hit by the Christine car
there was another reference I think
there was like the opening credits of
the movie and they wound up using that
oh my god
self-referential all right so what else
we get we got one last bit it's a
related to your Star Wars rogue one Star
Wars Star Wars what is this explain to
me this war install this sounds new
sounds a hip this is a tick-tock thing
this is the Star Wars I don't get the
quid ease I mean I watch it both ways
with my phone
did you see Rian Johnson put her between
her he was holding
the match from Lawrence of Arabia and
but it's it's like portrait sizes I got
man this kwibi version of florence of
arabia is the [ __ ] it's like the most
famous shot in history of all of its
residents i found in the age of the
pandemic coronavirus age i'm not nearly
as clever as i think i watch a lot of
tik toks where i'm like you should pay
this person a lot of money this is very
clever or touching did you see the one
about the guy that veterinarian no and
he's got a blind dog who's also deaf
what so like you can't wake that like if
you like oh I did see that one log if
you wake it up the dogs because in his
face he blows in this [ __ ] face this
is amazing [ __ ] everything else I'm just
gonna watch tick tock videos oh hey
blowing in that dog's face that's I
would rather watch that than someone
getting blown in a porn mark and then I
write by Tom called the highest pretty
yeah unless Taco Bell was like alright
and now she's grabbing his Chevy trailer
boss alright so back to star back to
Star Wars Disney Plus has already
announced they're doing a rogue one show
yeah what's his name I'm Cassie and and
or what's Cassie now and or yeah so it's
the sort of the story of Hannah who we
all know dies yes we see it happen but
it's a prequel story it's a sort of
journey through the resistance worried
it's like boy I hope I'd never die you
know what don't ever take me to the
beach bad things happened to me at the
beach so wait have they gotten closer
I'm not sure they just cast stellan
skarsgård oh he's great for the series
and you know Good Will Hunting he's
eaten well as well as of course all the
Marvel movie and pilot will be written
by Tony Gilroy oh he's good he's very
he's quite good he's very good right
yeah but he he co-wrote and did some
last he was the one that came in and
yeah and made rogue one and did a sort
of patchwork what everyone knows rogue
one to be yeah yeah Wow and he's a
self-confessed like I don't know
really I don't really don't care for
this yes he's like there was a Werner
Herzog I'm behind the camera
yeah I don't know if any much about this
Star Wars but that should be a [ __ ]
puppet but he's talent you know that's
what you want and and also there's some
continuity of service between the movie
and the actual yeah serious that's cool
yes a man like I'm all for it bring it
on but when do we get more mando I want
it's like August right
I want a mainline mandalorian into my
[ __ ] veins I haven't had a good time
watching something I haven't had as good
a time watching something over a period
of [ __ ] episodes and I can't remember
outfit maybe Watchmen you know what what
am i bitching about there's that
hospital few months ago I'm acting like
I'm starving and [ __ ] there's a lot of
good program but also Watchmen feels
like was 48 years ago you ain't kidding
since Watchmen since lo those many
months ago and we need him in no and
Watchmen was happening that the world
would [ __ ] turn into what it turned
it yep that's crazy but yeah she got
real for a second in our conversation
I'm gonna watchman when we had so much
hope Wow yeah man but yeah so that's
[ __ ] doctor Manhattan should have
given us all one of them eggs yes please
we all make some omelets but instead of
standing on line for an hour to get an
egg yeah now new version of Watchmen
he'd give her an egg but should be
wearing a mask like she already was once
again was ahead of the [ __ ] curve yes
and also maybe each starving deserves
all the awards when do they when do they
[ __ ] go like and the winner for Emmys
I'm not entirely sure many Emmys that's
a lot of words oh yes when Ken watchman
went we'll it hasn't passed right now
you know cuz I don't like I'll try to
vote for that that was that how good as
speaking of awards in a year that Kovac
cancels movie theaters after March yes
Sonic the Hedgehog or birds of prey when
best pictures whoa
Oh JC just took it to him it's actually
really entryway
because according to the Academy's rules
you need to play in a theater in either
New York in LA for at least a week yeah
to be eligible for an Oscar and there
are movies that are not going to get
that exposure because there's not gonna
be theaters to show it Josh Trank
one-time guest was the unfair man I mean
yeah I think it was because I wasn't
fantastic well not whether you might
have been the early version of the show
but maybe he was on spawn cast but Josh
Trank who directed Fantastic Four
he directed a Al Capone movie with Tom
Hardy called Fonzo that is now coming
out as Capone on streaming so in that
case because he's Josh is saying like
it's coming out streaming now but
there'll be some theatrical later on if
that's the case will Tom Hardy not be
eligible for playing Capone because the
movie didn't play and some [ __ ] movie
through do you think the Academy has to
relax that this year I mean sure it's a
conversation they're gonna have to have
I'm having it right now give me a
[ __ ] give me a solo hey MPAA relax
loosen your sphincter relax yeah it
would seem like in a world where a lot
of movies are like hey man [ __ ] controls
world tour went straight to streaming
yeah you mean to tell me they're not
gonna be eligible for an Oscar Anna
Kendrick's not gonna get a [ __ ] Oscar
nomination I don't want to live in a
world where [ __ ] justin timberlake
and anna kendrick don't get nods for are
they still the voices in metro black
they weren't the first one I am not sure
I don't know if that if it needs to
premiere in a theater or needs to play
in a theater because most of the world
in which yeah premieres and on streaming
and then there's a mad [ __ ] rush for
one screen and for the end of the year
yeah Wow we did my week I did my week
and you have we made $600 we made Kemp
Smith Manya and more than that it has to
have been reviewed by either the New
York Times or the LA Times
that's an MTA Athens an MPA a rule which
is insane it's a little uptight it's a
little antiquated really yeah that's the
term it's more antiquated
anything else leaves a lot of people out
of the mix it really does clusion area
yeah I mean something should be done now
is the time um have all of this device
you know really change your rules they
gotta lighten up man we didn't land on
Plymouth Rock Plymouth Rock landed on us
areas ladies and gentlemen he ain't
gonna win the Oscar for that but Marc
will win the Oscar for Malcolm X vote
what did he win for a training day
training day
Marc will win the Oscar for training day
more to make up for the fact that he
didn't win his Oscar for they will my
some X performance my shitty pins King
Kong it got nothing on me it's better to
do the Denzel finger there's always the
Denzel finger how how [ __ ] famous do
you think like Denzel will be for the
rest of his life and even when he passes
because whenever any name shows up on
Twitter like if somebody's like Betty
White is trending the first five
pictures at the top are always that clip
of him that's [ __ ] famous dude like
when he's the immediate that shot is
still the go-to to express oh thank god
yeah gives just like panic and then is
this and then I'm in a smile do you
think he knows I mean he must it's kind
of make him happy except that it's for
it's if I remember correctly that's from
the movie fallen is backwards yeah which
is like great dance but that moment
saved at that moment has been viewed by
more people probably than every movie
Denzel ever did put together now at some
point somebody's gonna monetize that
[ __ ] like how many gift views do you
have you ain't [ __ ] kiddin oh my god
is there a company we can start that'll
do that and so true it's bound to happen
well she's not ever in your entire life
think that you can get one over on me
which one was that I don't even remember
I just think that's every dance with the
finger
right no more news that's it man he gave
it a news but we did our best news is in
short supply can anybody think of any
other news no that was it right nothing
else happened this week not too much oh
there's a picture online Wonder Woman
that got out in Empire Magazine mm of
her you know [ __ ] throwing the lasso
around cheetahs arms its Kristen Wiig is
cheetah but she ain't cheated out it's
like she's wearing like cheetah clothing
but she looks like if I had to guess I
don't [ __ ] know anything but it's
early stage like if let's say she'd
taken some potion or whatever because
we've seen either Funko pops or Lego
figures for Wonder Woman toys that
depict a humanoid cheetah so Kristen
Wigg it looks like based on the toys is
gonna have feline features like cheetah
and the comics so in this one in this
picture she's not there yet she looks
like Kristen Wiig but she wearing like
cheetah print clothing and she's got her
arm like this and the lasso is around it
and Wonder Woman is across the room
pulling so it looks like she got some
strength there's also a picture of her
with the lasso around Maxwell Lord
played by Mandalorian star was his name
okay drop a scowl Pedro Pascal and he
was in narcos he was so good at narcos
so he's good in the Mandalorian but like
what a great job if he mask on the whole
time one shot it looked look at my
[ __ ] face and then when he takes his
mask off you're like she showed his face
every [ __ ] it's beautiful but it's a
genius idea right really you can't take
that [ __ ] helmet off because then
Pedro Pascal don't have to be there
every [ __ ] day no it wasn't what a
dream job so like we need you for the
last episode just to take the mask off
the rest of its voice work isn't done
and if if we are down to the describing
pictures we saw on the internet section
of the show
did you see the dune shots for manatee
fair let's let's talk let's we almost
left here without talking about the
first image they released was Timothy
sha'lame as Paul Atreides on the desert
planet Arrakis it looked like
Oh Caledon so he's before he goes right
because that's not wearing a still not
wearing still just him wearing his
absence [ __ ] and it's the so the picture
of him and Jessica his sister was she
was that on a rock mother picture well
isn't the what's the kid's name the
little girl's name his sister the one
Holly she was so terrifying who's the
actress who played her she's like a
legit actress oh [ __ ] she's gonna hate
me cuz I know her but they [ __ ]
looped her voice yes yes [ __ ] why can't
remember her name
don't come to its but it's awful I feel
bad yeah let's get some help
pull up dune see who played yeah yeah
that's his little sister yeah and she
becomes a Benny jezzer at which she does
like very because late at least so what
he played movie the Lady of him this is
the picture of Timothy Chou man is still
soon he's standing next to a girl mr.
Johnny zendaya no I didn't see I saw a
separate picture of Johnny by herself
but I saw a picture of Paul and it still
suits it standing next to
there's a girl and you're saying that's
his mom who's playing his mom I'm
Rebecca Ferguson you might be right it
might have been her she looks [ __ ]
young well I think she always was I mean
I thought I just I thought it was his
younger sister but you're right now that
thing about I'm sure mom she's good
actor she was in dr. sleep yes she's
definitely the last couple of minutes
parts of dr. sleep Wow alicia witt there
it is well done from fun fun and she was
on Walking Dead and she was on the Sybil
show I'm sorry Alicia that makes me feel
bad so wait a second I saw that picture
the picture of [ __ ] Duke Leto
Atreides looking up do initial Isaac
with the [ __ ] giant beard
did you see was that dude is it boss
logic who does the posters and he took
that shot and turned him into
Deathstroke that's true cuz he was like
he's the perfect does he put a patch on
him and change his outfit cause it looks
fantastic we're big denny build new fans
here man he's four I love [ __ ]
arrival
I love whatever he does he's the [ __ ]
truth so him doing this I'm on board
already but mark is a dune reader I'm it
yes you're a Herbert guy because I saw
the movie that the David Lynch movie I
must have been like 14 years old and
like my dad had brought it home on VHS
you went at it from our mom-and-pop
video store and and I watched it and I
had no [ __ ] idea what was going like
this is good fuse this is I don't
understand any even as a child you were
like I'm pretty sure the studio took
this away from the director like this
doesn't seem like it's got a singular
vision at work and then I rewatched it
immediately because it was for some
reason the kind of movie that I I didn't
understand but wanted to understand and
still didn't on the back end of it it
was like oh wait they're books
let me read these [ __ ] books and and
the first couple of books
it's dune and dune Messiah I think or
it's dune and dune God children of Earth
but they're amazing they're wonderful
there's these like these 60s written in
the 60s but it's all about kind of
ecology and the Superman and and you
know to hermetically sealed environments
and rebels Lucas Lucas cribs some stuff
right yeah I mean the I think in Star
Wars in a new hope their scenes when
when artoo and c3po are going through
the desert and you see the giant
skeleton skeleton is basically supposed
to be a sandworm it's supposed to be a
Shia Hulu that's crazy really so he's
like I acknowledge the fact that I was a
big dune reader I read oh I can't wait
but the performances in dune or so arch
it's not quite like mommy dearest but
like [ __ ] they're big they're very
big and they're fun because of it
yeah and we'll out your hand young cumin
let us see there is a place terrifying
to us all I see isn't a tradies I want
to kill who is this one a pet bat
remember fry again what's his name God
was his actor and actors names at Bruce
something guys McGill didn't know they
were the one who's like go be secret
make sure you're not seeing the hand
gestures he was in
he's a David Lynch regular yeah he was
in x-files he was the guy that was in
jail who was one episode during frat
Dourif excellent call and he was also in
[ __ ] uh he was in one flukish nest
yeah that's right he's the young guy who
stutters Billy yeah oh my god remember
him in that episode Abu higher-speed the
lips acquire staying by my will alone do
I set my mind in motion any drinks they
remember him in the episode the x-files
when Scully's dad dies in the beginning
and then they go to see him because he
can he'd know he's visions and [ __ ] but
he's on death row for killing people and
[ __ ] he was so [ __ ] good in that show
yeah he's a great actor a wonderful
actor um alright stellan skarsgård is
playing Baron Harkonnen stellan
skarsgård is playing the Giant Baron the
big your scheme the guy who is the one
who is like I just want to spit in your
face just a little spittle yes with a
very bad skin condition I read that that
characters rendering is going to be far
more grotesque than even that one and I
thought [ __ ] they did it alright job
I really thought Lynch made him [ __ ]
up and creepy and [ __ ] but it sounds
like they're gonna do even more so and
we'll have to get you think the third
stage navigators will still look like
giant testicles with vagina mouths I
hope so it's a very confusing character
for a young man going like there's balls
and a vagina what is turning me on more
I'll just jerk off to it all so hot
Frank Herbert's so hot
well not even left-handed you know
sometimes strangers sit on your left
hand instead of your right so yeah and
David just out to small chin you saw no
but he's in the movie oh I thought you
said you ran into a medic during the
[ __ ] epidemic wait he's in the movie
who's he playing I'm not sure he might
be playing the brad dourif role man he
might be he might be peter DeVries i
think the characters yeah yeah he might
be and i would be amazing
excited man I love dealt at Denny
Villeneuve and I think he's visionary
there looks like there's been and
[ __ ] ton of money looks expensive even
[ __ ] Khal Drogo is in it Momoa it's
playing Duncan Idaho who's not even if I
remember correctly a big character in
most no he's out after a certain point
yeah and so is I mean spoilers like but
this movies been around for a while as
is the book Duke Leto is out pretty
[ __ ] quick too yeah wonder Oscar
Isaacs like yeah I'll do it what do you
need me for
I'm in and I'm [ __ ] Thanos Thanos he's
in a - he plays gurney gurney Halleck
I'm in man what is this movie ready can
we see it tomorrow
we cannot nor could we even if it was
ready tomorrow why not they are they are
committed to a big screen - they're
spending so much money you can't can't
be like hey we see it for you know debut
on I feel bad they're gonna [ __ ] put
that it's December I think is the
release date so man think about it think
about how sweet that is we will have
been locked up forever you won't have
seen any [ __ ] movies can they around
the Oscars this year hmm even if like we
come out if movies open the movie
theaters open up in June July is that it
kind of short - year is that gonna be
it's gonna be a super sure it's always
because he could if it would this come
out no this is number this December yeah
that's why we're seeing pictures there's
no way this movie don't make like all
the [ __ ] award nominations and [ __ ]
same with what's his [ __ ] with tenet
Chris Chris Nolan's yeah if that's still
out this summer you don't know if it's
coming out this summer I mean it was
July like would you hear some [ __ ] it
was it was previously set for July and I
don't think then anybody is gonna open a
movie that expensive in July the brother
get away so where did they move Wonder
Woman to I want to say they moved it to
like December or December November like
in that so they got the [ __ ] out of the
summer though like yeah
Black Widow that got moved to like
November I think yeah I kept Disney
related a bunch of [ __ ] I don't remember
exactly what but they shifted everything
back like six months the tote board kids
is seems I'm gonna have to go over and
hit it it's stuck 18:35 at 1835 man so
if you want to do some Q&A
let's horse-trade
let's horse-trade last question if we
get up to 2,000 in the next let's say
three hours two minutes two minutes if
we get to the 2000 mark we'll do Q&A and
if not we'll wrap up and say goodnight
and stuff like that so basically you got
to want it open yeah you got that's
right yep like everything in life you
got paid for it man I will answer you
can queue us and we'll a the [ __ ] area
if we see the toe board hit mm in two
minutes
I can tell a bunch of you out there not
even hovering fingers over the button
right now like let's watch it fail this
is gonna crash your bird show's gonna
end he's not gonna do Q&A is he I don't
know we'll find out together so far
no no tip call never she went unheard
remember kids this ain't for us this is
for Bank
what is bank I keep asking you I think
is of charity what we're gonna go yeah
[ __ ] foundation org and donate there and
they're helping to facilitate relief to
independent bookstores of which comic
book owners fall into that category
that's right so what are the [ __ ] you
waiting for be a pinkie give us some
money so we can hand it over to Bank
don't be a stinky be a pinkie Fair
[ __ ] you shouldn't come up with that
two hours I gotta hope I woulda made us
some money took some iteration good job
check in the tow port I see that it's
still stagnant in 1835 either nobody's
watching or nobody's taking me serious
lose everybody like everyone signed off
is there another better stream going is
is Tom Hanks and the wonders performing
someplace I know muses on twitch right
now give me my [ __ ] 2-shot Jews you
pieces [ __ ] stealing the front good
people at 19:45 hold on Oh jump buy a
hundred bucks again that [ __ ] that's got
to be Donnie Cates right there
he wants you to put him on the glass
that's text 19 why Johnny we're doing
we're doing Q&A like he went in well
done pipe some cues into the feed will
lay the [ __ ] out of those yeah man you
want to hit us with
some Q's JC's here looking at where is
the best place that cutest YouTube live
chat is the best place right now ladies
and gentlemen YouTube live chat if you
put up a question in there
JC here is gonna feed it to us and we're
gonna respond man because you did
exactly what we asked you to do how
sweet we are less than 500 about 400 and
change away from our stated goal for the
evening which is really really sweet
thank you for everybody who was able to
throw a few bucks out there and stuff in
you we just made it to incentivize you
yeah we're not shaming at all stuff all
right do we have questions yeah we get
questions these guys put in last weekend
this week and I liked them what are
their names given those guys Xavier came
Savior Roberts creator of [ __ ] Cabbage
Patch Kids get him on the line he says
how is our things in Babyland General
that's it that's deep cuts joke if
you've ever been to Georgia you can
actually go to where the cabbage but
anyway back to JC Xavier says something
that I don't think spider-man far from
home touched on enough do to be he's
from overseas or know the movie takes
place overseas is the five-year time gap
can you both come up with a story within
that five years and he suggests Miles
Morales oh my god then why does he want
anything from us there's it that's
pretty great that's a great [ __ ]
answer because that should be running
[ __ ] whatever story that we would come
up with can't involve spider-man because
he's gone unless it's a new spider-man
in which case Miles Morales thanks man
you answer that question the only guy
who could have jumped to my mind was the
Asian kid who got older you know cuz he
didn't get zapped away no no he got
zapped away the other guy who was like
now I want to have yeah I'm gonna have
sex with [ __ ] Mary Jane he's Dex de
saint-jacques that he was one beautiful
man but he went from being a little kid
to being a grown up that's like everyone
else they saw got blipped away right
it's but that is a great story see
there's a creative there's somebody's
[ __ ] hungry man this old fool we
wouldn't come up with that we've been
fumbling around for some [ __ ] miles
is a great idea totally I mean it's it's
a little bit disingenuous to ask the
question you already have a great answer
for but I know but if you basically
wanted to be like well I'm gonna show
these [ __ ] dicks you just did it yep
in a big bad way took two weeks to come
up with a great end we told people give
us more money and we'll answer questions
and I can't even answer that it's so
good no response well done
all right ask us something else she had
something answerable this is EB Madsen
says if you had to recast the DCU movies
with actors who are in the MCU who would
you cast and then that's for Kevin and
then he wants to know who mark would
that do the flick so who from the MCU
would you recast in the DCU all right so
what am i doing
so who if you had to take the DC
Universe movies and put Marvel actors in
them like who what Marvel actor would
play Superman what Marvel actor would
play Batman Ark they want you to do the
Flip up so what DC actor would I use to
point you would you put in the basically
what justice league would you make
Avengers and then what
Avengers would you make Justice League
can I go I'm gonna I'll give you time to
think but I will take your category I'd
rather do DC to Marvel DC actors in
tomorrow movie yeah
okay you can have it DC to Marvel first
one Jason Momoa plays Kraven the hunter
hands down and I'm gonna drop the mic
because all right let's see who what are
their dcx Ben Affleck is playing you
know honestly this is good well well is
this some world some alternate reality
like I'm not gonna offend anybody by
being like this person's fired and this
person sorry this is just a world where
Robert Downey jr. never played right
Iron Man right correct Ben Affleck could
totally be [ __ ] Iron Man
totally charming his [ __ ] the only as
always felt like the only problem with
casting him as Batman was that he is so
like fun to watch so Kara charismatic
half of your role is you wearing a mask
and you know stuff like that he he you
know be a great Bruce Wayne and even you
know but Bruce Wayne to the public like
the Bruce Wayne behind closed doors is
essentially kind of Batman but Affleck
as Tony Stark I could totally see it
particularly because he's mostly if you
took the Robert Downey jr. approach and
you just played a version of yourself a
heightened version of yourself
Affleck one of the most charismatic
funny [ __ ] people I've ever met I
would totally cast him as Iron Man let's
see all right I mean Henry Cavill okay
well Wolverine I agree with the Internet
well the Internet's been saying it's not
an original idea but the internet was
like he should play Wolverine I was like
I just first I was like no and then I
was like you know what
yeah actually [ __ ] it looks pretty good
yeah I like why not him alright so Henry
Cavill plays my Wolverine let's see who
else we got
oh well Joaquin Phoenix isn't a DC movie
he's a pretty good actor
uh-huh he plays dr. doom Joaquin Phoenix
plays dude oh nice you know great actor
mask and [ __ ] like that he's such a good
actor he's playing it from behind a mask
and you're still loving it um let's see
Margot Robbie I wish I had a panic black
widow or Captain Marvel okay
that's cool I mean it's kind of easy
right because you just only I mean you
know there's more male characters so I
guess it's easier to be like oh well she
could play this but she's such a good
actress should play [ __ ] anything but
let's see who else I hope you've been
doing a lot of thinking I have yes
you're ready to steal as they second
Family Feud get ready to steal and
there's my third X all right player pass
play yeah all right the no-brainer is
Chris Evans as Clark Kent slash Superman
of course deal on Superman dies here he
has brown hair we can do that that's
true
Robert Downey jr. mmm-hmm oh you win I'm
sorry that lawyers out you [ __ ] win
that's the answer of the night Robert
Downey jr. as [ __ ] Lex Luthor I for
the first time in history I'd root for
[ __ ] Lex Luthor Oh excellent casting
call give me another one you may be hard
thank god this desk is here
outstanding Tom Holland is Barry Allen
oh my god that's clever that's good wait
was I doing
no I was doing be seated it's like are
you stealing my [ __ ] face yeah that
was my guy that's a good Paul right
there
Elizabeth Olsen as Wonder Woman about it
Scala Julie seems more like a Captain
Marvel think so I think so but you know
it's your list and also I'm going the
other way
you are yeah my bad I forgot the rules
of the game all right who are all
Johansson as Selena Kyle oh that's good
[ __ ] what's-his-face why can I'm bad
with names tonight Drax you played that
dude what is his what is Drax is normal
wrestler come on Internet oh my god I'm
she's joining - yeah
Dave Bautista diet Bhutan's to another
as as Bruce Wayne Dave Bautista plays
[ __ ] Batman yeah that is wait yes you
were allowed to do that that is that's
[ __ ] interesting cuz he would be like
this Batman the one that jumps out of
the [ __ ] bat will be able to fight
the [ __ ] mutant leaders you'd be the
one who looks the most out of place in a
suit yeah that's interesting take I like
Dave Bautista to see I would have been
like Killer Croc
but you're right [ __ ] what's-his-face
Chris Pratt yeah as Arthur curry the
Aquaman the Aquaman I think who else do
I have to play with Don Cheadle Don
Cheadle Don Cheadle is racial ghoul holy
[ __ ] that is I want to see that [ __ ]
move at ease I mean look he's wonderful
in these Marvel movies but like you want
to see [ __ ] Don Cheadle like destroy
it watch we were talking about Denzel
Devil in a blue dress remember though oh
yeah yeah he would be a great because
he's a great call
who else who else who else Paul Rudd oh
how much easier doing Marvel - I mean
Marvel cast because we know them all
right and it's it's a big cast yeah Paul
Rudd Booster Gold I I was literally
about to drop the microphone afraid to
take years of JC and Andrew such a good
call that be found that is an excellent
[ __ ] call oh I want to see your movie
much more money we got Mark Ruffalo who
he's your Batman he could've been a good
I don't take [ __ ] away from dave
bautista but i think he's your back um
you have Deathstroke who is Ruffalo you
got of his Deathstroke yeah although Jim
Gordon is not a bad puller I heard
Andrew in the corner Jim Gordon is a
pole that's good boy yeah Ruffalo is Jim
Gordon I could totally [ __ ] see that
ooh most of your answers were [ __ ]
genius give it up for Mark everybody
nobody great question thank you Greg
question now let's go to another JC
alright we've got I'm sorry are we at
$21.99 20 we are did somebody donate 20
cents I like it let's see what are your
guys favorite movie quotes what are my
favorite movie quotes and I am Iron Man
what else do I love from a man for all
seasons Paul Scofield is Thomas More
says when a man takes note the old is
his self his soul in his hands like
water and if you open your fingers he
cannot help he cannot hope to find
himself again that always stuck with me
not like [ __ ] not like you know go
ahead make my day obviously it's a much
longer quote what other me I mean almost
every Cohen Cohen brothers [ __ ] quote
my name is H ah McDonagh like I could do
all of Raising Arizona
how about you the riddle of Steel you
know what it is don't you boy but the
riddle of Steel I'll give you the secret
flesh is stronger what a steel compared
to the hand that wields it look at that
woman there look at her do it
come to me my child oh that is strength
boy that is power
he was so emphatic that is strength boy
that is power so wait such a pity
crucify him on the tree of woe oh that's
[ __ ] excellent excellent what is best
in life
Oh Grob I do not pray to you I have no
tongue for it and if you do not help us
the ten virtues I always thought when I
was a kid I was like cuz I was Catholic
kid I was like you [ __ ] yourself at
the end yeah you don't [ __ ] go like
help me if not to hell with you because
that's how [ __ ] Santa Bergman died
that's the loophole Conan he wasn't
thinking but he was a barbarian so to be
fair it's a transmitter it's a range so
radio for talking to God do you want to
see God let's go see him together
oh that's great I hadn't thought about
that no Wow some things in here Ryan do
Iran react well to bullets great line
when I left you I was but a learner now
I am the master I love you I know we're
gonna need we're gonna need a bigger
boat not the years it's the mileage
who's that Indiana Jones
Indiana Jones I don't remember that one
not the man you used to be remember
you're Charlemagne my army is the badge
and I think probably a lot of jaws if I
thought about it right aside from we're
gonna need a bigger boat jaws two
springs to mind
I know what that is that's a shark I
know what one looks like cuz I've seen
it up close you better do something
about this one because I'm not going
through that hell again and I [ __ ]
fired
do you think that's air you're breathing
do you think that your strength in your
body has anything to do at a place like
this was a Morpheus oh I know I know God
let me see if I could still do it 20 in
invasion of the mutants for 20 50 ad
Sega off they saw it already
no they got to see it take off I was the
only one left on the planet after the
Holocaust de Russia blew up the US and
the u.s. blew up Russia as strange group
a gun not a lot of people know that
great that made me happy yes and rest
well and dream of large women hair of
the dog that bit me Lloyd hair of the
dog that bit me
yeah see honey it's okay he saw it on
television I am the monarch of the sea I
am the ruler of the cool you knew enough
what was that marry and basically he's
still [ __ ] running Raiders once I can
read it's like all [ __ ] good evening
Fraulein yes we are thirsty
no time for love dr. Jones oh we are
going to die that's him in that [ __ ]
putting his mouth through the [ __ ]
hole two days ago I saw a tank of it at
whole you are right two days ago I saw a
rig than a hole you attack it you want
to get out of here
talk to me we named the dog Indiana I
should have bought it my favorite line
in that home of is we should have mailed
it to the Marx Brothers such a
disappointment it was actually like you
know I remember when I first saw that
movie I was like oh man like it wasn't
like Temple of Doom was like only [ __ ]
Satanism and [ __ ] like that
kind of not saying this but Kali and
then when they got to this one it was
like oh like that you know what happened
a [ __ ] poem hearts out of chest and
[ __ ] like that but I learned to
appreciate that movie as time went on my
old man loved it because he loved Sean
Connery oh my god but it was like I
don't want to see Indiana gee I was
getting dressed down but his dad and
then the older I got I was like I do
kind of want to see that I'm going to
leave you as you left her stranded on a
dead Rock buried alive it's coming
through now Khan you have to learn why
things work on a starship revenge is a
dish best served cold
it's and what is it it's even colder see
the space you keep missing the target
god we could do it all night and we
haven't made a penny doing
$21.99 20 nobody's given us a buck or 80
cents for any of that so Tracy [ __ ]
nerds next question Casey wants to know
what color like savers you guys would
have you give me the dark saber man that
[ __ ] looks metal ma'am and a minimun and
ma'am and a minimum absence of light
ma'am it him in a minute you flesh less
lightsaber could you imagine you would
really throw off your opponent's you
like Shuang Shuang like that looks like
a dick oh and then you got have been run
through by a giant phallus the phallus
savior I liked his better what else we
got hey we finally got a few bucks now
we're 2204 talked about dicks yes that's
right keep it going more dick questions
yeah if you could put James Alan Bob in
any Marvel movie which one do you think
they would fit in the most I mean
honestly they'd be probably most at home
in a the spider-man movies seem light
enough I want to say guardians but them
in space makes no [ __ ] sense but
those two dudes hanging outside a
convenience store in Queens I could see
it you know not for the whole plot
they're not like you know it's just hey
[ __ ] hey there goes hey it's Maury
Povich or whatever [ __ ] like just I'll
let them come up with the writing you
know a little cameo and [ __ ] that's what
I want more than anything in this life
man [ __ ] people always think you want
to make a Marvel movie don't you and I'm
like [ __ ] no that's a lot of
responsibility but I would love to be in
a Marvel movie because number one
everyone sees those Marvel movies number
two I love those Marvel movies number
three they put you in shape you saw
[ __ ] what they did to come out holy
[ __ ] my man's got like shelves going
down to his dick like muscle shelves
that you see on [ __ ] like he's got
like a seven packed like here's my six
and like one bonus one and it's part of
the job they look by the way this sucks
but you're getting paid to get in shape
automated listening to today's podcast
no it's staying in with Kumail and Emily
wife are not doing sort of a listen guys
we've been working from home for the
last six years like we are home bodies
and now we're in this sort of scenario
we're all doing it let us give you some
advice that you know people have work
from home and who are married and have
to now be
confined with each other right and it's
also because the two of them they're
[ __ ] hilarious but he talks about the
fact that like a week after they were
quarantined because Emily his wife has a
has an autoimmune disorder and so for
her something like this it's like it
infection is yeah yeah c'mon buyers to
be like the worst yeah
and so like they were like Heather like
they're all her [ __ ] shopping they
knew very early on that like we are
going to have to
they went to stay at home before anybody
was told to stay at home right but it
was like yeah we were in the house for
like a week and my men's health cover
drops which is like the [ __ ] like
look at me world and my crazy [ __ ]
body and and he was like I I was looking
so much forward to it two weeks ago and
now I could give a [ __ ] he's like you
know the the realignment of my
priorities is such that now I'm just
overly concerned about my wife but I
gotta like go on the Twitter and I gotta
do the contractually obligated social
media and I gotta say hey guys you
should read this when my mind is
absolutely not on you no [ __ ] work
that I did but he did a [ __ ] ton of work
because they sent over the Chris Pratt
guy they send over the Paul Rudd guy was
like alright our specialty is turning
like somewhat doughy comedians into
Adonis's will give you the V yeah the V
down to your dick so like that's what I
want I want to give that Marvel V down
to my dick man so way more than making
one of them being in them one of them
would be awesome yeah just send that
dude over to my house and that had that
be my job for six months because to just
work out twice a week and eat the shitty
food you got to eat and then sooner or
later you come up for air and people
like what the [ __ ] happening you think
holy [ __ ] I got marbleized I got a
marvelous body yeah alright what else we
got a lot of people want to see Jay and
Silent Bob in a movie called the
infinity stoners yeah Louis from ant-man
Michael Payne is character the chat was
show I was speaking of Michael Pena
I watched the Fantasy Island did you how
was love house did a Fantasy Island I'm
it was like you know it's totally
watchable particularly it for a home
watching ship but he's wonderful
no he says I'll watch him do anything
but it was you know I don't think I
would have made a better Fantasy Island
movie mmm yeah I thought it was like
cool they took it darker I mean the show
even like as I remember very loosely it
got to a place that's it like in the 3rd
season where is season 1 it's just a
[ __ ] vacation show it's Love Boat but
there's an island Love Boat with an
island it did start getting darker they
started going darker so I guess mr.
Roarke actually like an angel like a
fallen angel and is this some level of
purgatory and these are people who need
to like earn their way back or sink
deeper into the into the pit I'm like
that's [ __ ] fast that is kind of a
cold so it was that show when I was 9
this was I wouldn't say quite that but
more along the lines of like you know
[ __ ] he's not the nicest guy in the
world yeah and there there's a reason
but yeah he's perhaps the island is a
shady place I kind of like you know this
segment of the Blum House business which
is let let us take a piece of IP that
you have some familiarity with and tweak
the [ __ ] out of it mark just saw
invisible man I just saw invisible man
and you talked about it like three weeks
ago and I finally was like I will spend
twenty dollars to rent this for a date
[ __ ] good as leach really cuz really
like as a writer and as a filmmaker I
was like this is some good [ __ ] like
it's it cluttered there there's the
version of this story that is like large
and wild and big sci-fi and you know
invisible [ __ ] happening and what can we
drape on him now and they were really
smart and like we don't need a lot of
money to tell the story and the story
that we want to tell is a character
piece about a woman who is trying to
convince herself she's not going mad you
know and the source is a sadness of that
insanity is an abusive husband and it
becomes personal and and it becomes a
story about surveillance and about
stalking and about abuse and about like
standing up for yourself and choosing to
leave and fighting for what you believe
in to the point where that thing has to
even be yourself and it twists exactly
what it needs to twist and the people it
around me a bit of get out
and no surprise coming from plumb house
is that the one of the genius things
about get out is that you're with that
character Michael and every time the
audience wants him to leave he wants to
leave because it starts to feel weird
and then the movie gives him reasons to
stay it's like dude just okay listen I'm
gonna stay for you you're my girl and I
get you these are your parents and you
love them and I love you so this is all
[ __ ] weird and I get it but I'm gonna
stay for you and then when he's like we
need to leave these girlfriend says you
know what let's leave you don't feel
comfortable let's go like it it
anticipates where the audience is and it
leans into it and I love that you're
never you're never shouting to the
screen for that character to do
something that she should do and doesn't
do right don't go in there yet so don't
do that don't do that
I [ __ ] love the suit yes any spoilers
if you haven't seen it one two three he
don't take a potion it's technology and
it's you know [ __ ] movie technology
but it was just enough sci-fi
gobbledygook with he's an optics and
then later on it's like he's wearing a
[ __ ] suit with a little tiny cameras
that pop in and out I was like this is
dope it had a comic-book feel to it yeah
I mean that is a suit there's been
there's been experiments into because of
course nerds are also scientists and
they wanted my cloaking devices because
I got saw on a [ __ ] Star Trek how
could we make a legit cloaking device
right and you know they're a little bit
of the way there where there was some
dude who like built some kind of blanket
and the blanket has a camera behind him
and in the front of the cameras a bunch
of tiny LED cameras and so it looks as
if he's not there and so when he moves
it is just showing you what's behind him
projecting it in front so it looks like
he's not there they did that in a movie
I remember oh they're going down the
hallway with a projection it's a mission
impossible mission impossible for Ghost
Protocol I think and it's the like if
you can get in the right perspective you
can trick the eye and to see in kind of
whatever you want to do and that the
realizes we get to invisibility yeah but
like it's one of those here's a bit of
science that we're just going to push a
little bit and it's less fantasy and
it's just science fiction was that this
year Invisible Man
because that could totally [ __ ] win
awards like I thought I was incredibly
well done yeah I mean it's in the same
world that get out wings the Best
Original Screenplay Oscar not just
nomination but Oscar know this this has
the capacity like it's it is social
science fiction in social horror the
same way that get out well I like that
social science fiction so yeah I really
really dug it super [ __ ] smart 22:54
19 [ __ ] with the 19 sense
like what's going on tip jar here's a
nickel
no really like I gave you five somebody
donated 420 even it out what they were
doing it at the same time that's
hysterical we're glad that they give it
all it's really [ __ ] kind yeah we are
up to 22 64 64 19 within like [ __ ]
200 and change of the goal we set out
for ourselves that's great it's so
lovely we'll take let's do two more
questions and then get the [ __ ] out of
Dodge
all right let's see Eve here we go here
you know what here you go let's get this
to twenty five hundred if you get us
there it's to what is the twenty to
sixty four
so about twenty two so two hundred and
thirty bucks to thirty six you get us
there
me and Mark will throw in some money for
[ __ ]
yeah I'll throw in a grand [ __ ] grand
we should have talked about this I
[ __ ] said some money mark Jesus all
right
a grand it is man thousand bucks there a
thousand bucks here man so you get us to
twenty five hundred before the end of
the show yeah now you got to beat a
clock it's a game and [ __ ]
you guys 2500 we will each donate a
thousand of our Hollywood writer dollars
and they're huge lazy John the writers
are overpaid in this business so you get
us their kids in the next it give us a
countdown JC I'm talking some questions
what do we got it's 937 so by 1945 37
what [ __ ] 45 they got eight minutes yes
nine forty if in the next three minutes
we hit 2500
we throw in each throw in a thousand
bucks per [ __ ] but if we don't we will
never mention big again thanks mother
buggers y'all love comic book stories
we're bad guys now man this is a super
villain movie you have a chance to save
it
we're ransoming the future yes that's
right our money is ready to go into the
pot but it's up to you to get us there
you guys are the Joker standing over the
pile of money with a giant [ __ ]
gasoline can for 220 bucks don't have to
be one person can be like a hundred
people at 2 bucks apiece we'll hit that
goal and then we'll jump in 19 almost
2000 people watching now and chat oh
that's like awesome each thank you for
only 394 so they just toss in a hundred
bucks
we're almost there look at that well
done kids
Polly Donny Cates again okay so you're
gonna have any money from writing if you
keep [ __ ] buying things for people
I'm very sweet alright last question of
the night are we doing two questions no
we're doing now we remember them we
changed it we're like I'll [ __ ]
alright make it as up as I go along I'm
like don't you know what's in my hand
494 2525 1919 it looks like your mayor
[ __ ] we were gonna high-five Oh can't
do this [ __ ] anymore we will be throwing
in because I imagine you got to connect
it to something right how do we do this
well we'll probably go direct to being
yeah beautiful so we're good for a
thousand bucks peace how sweet we hit
the [ __ ] figure that's amazing guys
well done everybody
it takes a village a global village
indie and all that money every penny of
its going to bank me and mark throwing
in another grant apiece so with 2500
bucks and an O 25-minute buck 4,500
bucks for Bank and our friends at the
local comic book store a night's work
well done every well done everybody and
was even hard work we were having fun
and we [ __ ] talked to Jim Lee for
chrissakes hell yeah alright here's what
the last question take us on Baba all
right
nutty wants to know who should play
Stanley in a biopic great question great
question to go out on you
who plays Stanley in a biopic well not
Tom Hanks he just did mr. Rogers and he
also doesn't have a I mean he's got a
stand disposition that's for sure he's
sweet her and [ __ ] but he doesn't he
don't seem like Stan to me a lot of
people always said Breaking Bad what's
his name
Bryan Cranston who I played poker with
online during bends tournament over the
weekend
yes Bryan Cranston like totally B stand
like circa 70s and [ __ ] like 70s and 80s
and stuff age him up later on for the
stand the later years he did a great job
as Trumbo so he's a really nice choice
but let me think outside the box like
Don Cheadle wait Morris Don Cheadle for
Roger such a good pole I would like to
see Don Cheadle is Stan Lee
I'm cheeto could pull it off is that
good an actor if you've not seen double
on a blue dress if you'll watch it
you'll be like Don Cheadle could totally
play standard hmm those remind who do
you go
I've to okay and it's weird because I
don't know how much of that life you
want to tell yeah
whether or not you're gonna focus on the
early years whether it's the entire
sweep of you know Stanley Lieber
starting at timely comics all the way up
to you know editor-in-chief emeritus I
feel like Marc Maron could be pretty
good I think there's there's a sort of
hangdog energy to him that's kind of
interesting it's funny though I don't
think and I ain't trying to take
anything away from Marc but I don't
think of [ __ ] Stannis hangdog Stan was
like hey you're gonna crazy Eddie got a
place he had Stan's energy yeah I mean
big I think like I think the the the the
workaholic version of Stan which he was
as well as the public persona of which
he was I think you can get that duality
with somebody like that which is kind of
like fun cuz he his guy rope superheroes
and so you'd be writing a dual versions
yeah and the guy in the bullpen who was
more of the
administrator and the guy who was
tub-thumping for comics out in the world
and then I thought about like Zach Braff
a young Stan yeah like the sort of the
young we're getting it started like I'm
I'm betting on myself I'm trying my
dream and write this [ __ ] book and you
know Joanie by his side saying you
should absolutely do this buddy and like
you do the early years of Marvel to sort
of halcyon the the you know between 64
and 78 Stan Lee like a Mad Men version
yeah you do like the young [ __ ]
upstart version of that well let's think
about Avengers is there anybody in the
Avengers cast that you would cast it
that it could be Stan Lee what about our
DJ it depends I mean yeah yes the
Energy's a particularly like circus
seventies eighties Stan when Stan comes
out to Los Angeles that's a yeah like
from that era on up into the I could see
him pulling it off - is there a version
of this it would be interesting but you
remember that Bob Dylan biopic I'm not
we're a bunch of different people I
don't you know I'm not here I think
you're not here and like you know like
Heath Ledger was him for once and I
think Gwyneth Paltrow Cate Blanchett
okay that was that that was the blonde
actress those things you could do that
have a bunch of people play that's smart
yeah I have a bunch of different cool
people placed and including some woman
the way they had Cate Blanchett play one
chapter and chef you know and I think
that that that lets you it gets to be an
homage to that guy by all the people who
you know loved him and whether it's
everybody who's in the MCU whether it's
just actors in general storytellers in
general but I think that it could be
really interesting version of that story
and you get to tell the not to say
cradle to grave but the the arc of his
life in ways you don't have to da Jar DJ
to play young Stan you don't have to age
up so I like Jack it's like I have to
play old Stan you can just do all of it
I'll tell you right now whoever it is as
a tough [ __ ] mountain to climb
because you want to talk about
one-of-a-kind you want to talk about
like there's as we sit here going oh who
could do him nobody could pull up that
guy's energy off nobody could [ __ ]
capture the magic it was like watching
Gandalf
speak whenever he spoke whenever he
talked like yeah and I'm sure somebody
could do a pretty decent impression but
he I think I think it'd be virtually
impossible to do a stand that even
approximates the stand that stand built
you got the remember he built that
character over course of decades and
what went out of this world the stand we
all knew was him worn to perfection in
the character of Stanley tough to ask
any actor in the world to be like can
you pull off in six months but this man
took 50 years to [ __ ] perfect yeah I
mean I it's a it's a it's a tough bill
to to whatever the appropriate phrase is
hard act to follow
shoes to fill but then you look at
something like Taron Egerton as as Elton
John who similarly was like here's the
me that I was and here's the me that I
built for the public and you get to
watch that guy switch between the two
within a scene can I make a casting
suggestion yeah this is very off the
beaten path okay but I'm just trying to
think of energy that you're matching
because Stan had this very specific
energy this is this gonna be
controversial mmm this is going to you
know get a lot of people angry but if
you think about it and you think about
the energy of the person I'm gonna
present you might be like I'm kind of
see if they're completely different in
size Quentin Tarantino Quentin Tarantino
has as much energy when you talk to him
as Stan always had and as Stan was like
single-mindedly passionate about his
field so as Quentin I could see Quentin
pulling off [ __ ] Stanley I'm glad one
of us does I don't know
is there anybody agreeing with me JC
there a minute behind us enters another
booth go no no not
guys say they can see it right right the
energy is what I'm talking about
does that count for anything somebody
says QT is too much energy he would have
to dial it back but that's the point of
a performance you dial it back a little
bit I didn't blow it up you like Quentin
as an actor man
I think he's got like something special
like the way that lamb not saying he's
good as Brad Dourif but the way that
Brad Dourif does something very like
specific were like I like him and
everything I like when I think he's a
good actor oh you know he'd be really
good go to [ __ ] what did I tell that'd
be amazing in a world where we do the
stand movie with a bunch of different
people playing Stan oh yeah and Zell
definitely plays one of them he plays
like the older standing you get [ __ ]
childish gambino like young Stan get in
there Walton Goggins oh good good you
know oh that that's a dude who I mean
I've seen crazy energy version of Walton
right but also like kind of cerebral and
and sort of inward focusing and the
duality of that character of that person
is I mean you need a Titanic actor to
pull it off and I think that he's he's
the kind of person who could do that
George Carlin would have been great mmm
he had a Stan energy and also he had the
age too so that would help again you
depending on which Stan you're doing
like Stan left as sadly left this world
but he left this world after 90 almost
six years 95 verging on 96 so he's also
one of the most sprightly and [ __ ] in
shape you know what were they called
nonagenarian that I've ever seen in my
life like good luck finding an actor to
play that guy like oh boy what a great
question absolutely and it resulted in a
lot of chitchat and stuff and fond
memories of good friend not just good
friend but a guy who made all this [ __ ]
possible we don't get to sit around and
be fans of things were it not for the
great Stan Lee going like hey this
shit's legit a minute what not he was
the first fan there it is
we gave you a lot of information we
showed you people talking about their
business there comma business or their
comic book store business we covered the
[ __ ] news we for twenty minutes we
just tried to think of our favorite
movie lines you know I start feeling
like Michael Scott where he's always
like trying to think of like I'm
thinking of one right now like so
[ __ ] slow I realize it was such a
stoner but that is a Friday night man oh
yeah I'm fat man beyond do you have a
good time ladies and gentlemen well I
can hear them thank you for being here
man thank JC and Andrew let us come into
the scum and villainy Cantina and do
this show for you all and whatnot
don't forget the pink what is it Bing
Bing Foundation org and thank you again
to Jim Lee and car D'Angelo for taking
time out of their Friday nights in some
cases retreating from their Mountain
hideaways and returning to LA to a good
Wi-Fi signal to be able to talk to us in
fact the Lord yeah thank you for that
thank all of you who gave money for
tonight's cause it's just bank and
whatnot really [ __ ] cool of you guys
to do that whatnot and we'll be right
there with your throne and a grand
apiece afterwards man cuz we love comic
book stores too we don't get to be who
we are in life without the local comic
book store so comic books rule there you
go and look we make like we made a
[ __ ] good living awful liking comic
books you know we said all right totally
weird all right
not as good as like you know [ __ ] the
Russo brothers they yes they got all but
but worthy worth of worth it because
they're [ __ ] talented [ __ ] because
comics gave us a lot so it's the least
we could do is give some back is what I
was trying to say thank you a better
writer than their thanks for hanging out
all those ladies and gentlemen but there
is no show without the man to my left
give it up for mr. mark Bernardo thank
you and that is fat man on Batman for
this week man so throwback Batman sorry
that is fat and Batman Beyond doing too
many things at once I was the old-school
Lucasfilm logo
it was in honor of JC there's a little
memo that is Fatman beyond for this week
man I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark Barnard
tune in next week same fat time same fat
channels Marquez calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith for the good of all
Cree although I did the Star Trek
you